[Music]
so I usually have pretty good idea of
where I'm going to start these
conversations and I'm looking at this
list and it's like a combination of
momento meets Forest
Gump meets Globe trotting and I'm going
to let you choose so should we start
with and with this will be very back and
forth we're going to fast forward rewind
so we can start at any point really
Charlie tuna or why PID $25,000 to buy
[__] yourself.com just to get an email
address or pilgrims where should we
start whoa all right let's start with
Charlie tuna because it inspires all
else
perfect who the hell or what the hell is
Charlie tuna in college I studied
management information systems which was
basically a hybrid of business and uh
computer science I chose that because
quite pragmatically as I am it was at
that time in
1990 mid90s the highest paying job out
of college and so I said well that's
what I'm going to do so I did that and I
started a software business and in in
eastampton as a matter of fact I quickly
realized that it was not what I want to
do with my life and so I then
subsequently graduated a few months
later after coming to that realization
with a degree in something I didn't want
to do and I had no idea what I was going
to do with my life and I got a call from
so-called Charlie tuna very very close
friend somebody I would call a mentor
and an extraordinarily unique individual
on this planet Peter murky so I get a
call from Peter murky Peter says do you
want to come sell fish how did he get
your name or number or both so Peter
Peter contacted uh University of Rhode
Island where I went to school he
contacted the business school and he
said I'm looking for an entrepreneurial
you know go-getter to become my mini me
Peter wanted to retire and he wanted to
train somebody that had not come from
the seafood industry that's what we call
foreshadowing
folks he wanted to train somebody to
basically take over the business in his
own you know image and I was the chosen
one so anyways I basically told him to
go pound sand and and then at that point
he offered me $1,000 to come hang out
with him for the day in Newport Rhode
Island and and I did and it was kind of
like I love at first sight I just we hit
it off I walked into the office in a in
a business suit with a tie on and a
briefcase my resume in the briefcase you
know the secretary let me into his
office and he had his feet up on the
desk and he was blowing out a bong hit
and he looked at me and he said if you
ever come in my office in a suit again
it'll be the last time you ever come in
my office what was he wearing he was
wearing a like a Native
American Poncho type of thing and he's
got you know long hair with a ponytail
and this unique beard that that I don't
know only only Peter can carry and he's
a brilliant man he he's a Stanford grad
an Old Hippie he just has a unique
perspective on the world and I've never
encountered anybody else that sees the
world the way that he does and I think
it was probably the most important event
in my life because I'm ambitious and I'm
aggressive and I'm you know full of
energy and ready to go you know tear the
ass out of the world but without any
real
Direction isn't always the weapon suited
to the task absolutely not absolutely
not but at that age you know it's better
than it's better than nothing and Peter
was very good at harnessing that and
pointing it in certain directions so I
went under Peter's wing and and I spent
eight years in the seafood business the
Frozen Seafood business I traveled the
world I negotiated with I couldn't even
imagine the number of different
countries and the types of people I
literally did business with some of the
worst people on Earth you know the fish
business is a cash business basically
worldwide and so you know it's a it
itself to certain elements and it was
just an amazing life experience so walk
me through what it looks like let's just
say your first week or month on the job
like how is the compensation set up and
what are you actually trying to do so my
first day on the job I come into the
office obviously no longer wearing a
business
suit and I sit down at my designated
desk now there's only about I don't know
at that time four or five people and so
I sit down on my desk and I don't know
you know an hour or two later Peter
comes out of his office and he comes
over to me and I'm basically sitting
there doing nothing I've got some
reading material that somebody's given
me to uh look
over and he he walks over to my desk and
he points at a poster on the wall that
says
exactitude and he says do you know what
that means and I said no and he said
have you ever read the book Atlas
Shrugged I said no he said have you ever
heard of it I said no he says do you
know who IR and is I said no went into
his office without saying a word went
into his office got a copy of ATL
Shrugged brought it back to me and he
said go home now and I was he's like go
read this book don't come back in until
you're done so I literally for I went
home and I literally took about five
days to read the book it's a big it's
not a short book no it's not it's a big
book and it's not easy reading either uh
at least the first like 200 Pages it's
like a 200 Page intro and so
I read the book I came back in it was
kind of like a fifth grade what do you
call that like a book book report book
review right and I guess I don't know I
guess I passed that was it and then and
then it was like okay look you know come
with me and he took me down to New
Bedford Massachusetts and drove me
around to these different scallop
processing facilities and I met some
absolutely crazy people amazing amazing
people these are these are just you know
truly to this day like I I was just
actually back in Rhode Island in
September the end of September you know
I met up with some of these guys that I
hadn't seen in in you know a long time
and you know brought me right back they
really just amazing people you just
don't you I'm sure there's other
Industries like that but but Seafood is
a really
special you know truly salt of the earth
business and it's such a dichotomy from
from you know the business I'm in today
so in that Boiler Room what did
exactitude mean why was it on the wall I
think it means different things to
different people to Peter to Peter what
it meant was having the right
information in order to arrive at the
right answer he did not like knee-jerk
reactions he didn't like knee-jerk
answers or in Precision so once you've
read Atlas Shrug which I'll admit I have
not read but I know so shame unto me
once you've read that you come back five
days later at that point is it some form
of Arbitrage like what is the business
model yeah basically
so what's remarkable is is Peter's
business is still going today I think
now it's 40 it's got to be 40 years now
I think it was 30 years yeah I think he
started in 1985 so so roughly 40 years
38 years he doesn't own a factory he
doesn't process he doesn't own boats
he's primarily scallops there's other
businesses but it's let's say core
businesses scallops and all of his
competition 100% of his competition owns
at a minimum they own the processing
plant most of them own
boats most of them have you know joint
ventures or Partnerships with foreign uh
processors aquaculture Etc and despite
these seeming disadvantages Peter has
been
Nimble and you know he's kept his
overhead low and through the good times
and the bad he's just kept that business
running and in great times he buying and
then reselling buying putting in his in
in his packaging in some
cases I don't know if we want to go into
that today but you know what call it
value ad we can skip we can skip certain
details if you know they're they're
they're they're you know they would say
they're value adding and repackaging and
then you know reselling MH and it's it's
a pure Arbitrage so what was the annual
turnover and I'm going to I'm going to
hop to a specific example so what was
the annual
revenues roughly when you started there
they were doing about 7 or 8 million a
year when when I
started yeah and how did it grow so I
became the quite quickly uh we realized
I was I was good at this game and I
became the Vice President of Sales and I
think when we left we were about 35
million okay yeah how do which is a lot
of scallops yeah how do Hokkaido
scallops fit into this picture Northern
island of Japan for people who may not
know yep a couple of years in you know
so basically this is this is a pure
sales game right so I'm I literally have
the equivalent of a a phone book but
it's it's the who's who of the seafood
industry and I'm literally making about
I don't know 150 calls every day and
it's just cold calling cold calling
you're selling to Distributors to
restaurants to no no restaurants
primarily
Distributors other wholesalers
restaurants supply companies cruise
lines I say no restaurants but large
restaurant chains which is where we're
going with the story but a couple years
in I come across Benny Hana and I call
up you know the Fort Lauder headquarters
of Benny Hana and you know you guys want
to buy some scallops and it just you
know pure luck that they happened to be
in a transition period where they were
they had been getting all of their
Seafood from one company mhm and they
decided that they could get better
pricing and and there was other
advantages by put out a put out a bid
put out a bid for each individual
product
mm and so it was just great timing and
so I had the opportunity to you know put
in a bid and and you know by any stretch
of the imagination I shouldn't have had
any chance of winning the
contract but as fate would have it you
know I did my due diligence on the buyer
and he was
Nicaraguan by descent and he loves
cigars and Peter happened to be a cigar
connoisseur and so he sent me to his guy
who could basically Source any cigar and
he you know I said look I'm looking for
you know an amazing amazing cigar that
if it happened to be from Nicaragua
might even give me an extra Edge but
something that's going to be really wow
and he said I've got a cigar for you now
I I couldn't even tell you what that
cigar is but it was it was a a very
expensive very good cigar I got a box of
them so I flew down to Fort Lauderdale
and I took this guy out to dinner and I
gave him this box of cigars and the fact
that I knew he was from Nicaragua the
fact that I happened to know this I
didn't actually know but he he thought I
did this this brand of cigars it was
literally I couldn't have nailed this
you know I I I nailed it and so we had
an amazing dinner and we drank way too
much and you know ultimately I made this
sales piture about Hokkaido scallops I
said look you guys are using American
scallops okay and American scallops are
great arguably if you're getting them
pure form which it's very difficult it's
the best in the world however pure for
meaning like unadulterated unadulterated
you know a couple days crab meat yeah
yeah yeah type of scallop yeah yeah
that's the least of your
worries it's the value adding part that
it's not so you're eting guinea pigs
yeah yeah
so you know the interesting part of this
was basically American scallops are
graded 0 to 10 10 to 20 20 to 30 and
that's basically 0 to 10 per pound 10 to
20 per pound 20 to 30 per pound but the
Japanese as they do grade them much more
consistently and so it's 0 to2 two to 4
4 to 6 6 to 8 8 to 10 and that tightness
of grading makes an enormous difference
if you are a restaurant and you're
trying to calculate your plate cost
right so you want your plates to be
consistent you can't be that one plate
has four scallops one Plate's got six
and oh well I've got this one giant
scallop and so now my plate cost is
thrown off so that inconsistency and
scallops are one of if not the most
expensive per pound protein from the sea
and so it makes a big difference and so
I basically made this whole pitch about
look you guys can have consistent
plating consistent plate cost and and
just you know there was a lot more to it
but that that message resonated and and
it closed the deal and I got the
contract and it literally became our our
largest client and I supplied all of
Benny Hana worldwide all their scallops
and I subsequently became basically the
world's leading expert on Hokkaido
scallops
uh so how did you was it a known fact in
the industry that Hokkaido scallops had
these advantages
nobody cared so how did nobody cared
because they were taking the packaging
that came from Japan and they were just
repacking it into
American uh uh standards right and so it
was just another source just like we got
scalps from China we got scalps from
Chile from Peru it was just another
origin high quality but you know yeah
the grading wasn't a known selling point
so what made you good I mean I have some
we've spent a good amount of time
together so I have some guesses but
rather than guess what do you think made
you good at this job I'm not afraid to
sell I think I have to start there is
that that you know I've just I took it
for granted that I don't know I didn't
you know oh hand me a phone book I'm
going to start making Co calls I'm going
to get on the phone with people try and
sell them something that they you know
never knew they need never knew they
needed I you know I I I I think that was
you know that was a big factor and then
you know I've got the gift to gab I'm
rarely at a loss for words I'm very good
at adapting to people and meeting people
where they are whereas I think a lot of
people in sales are trying to bring
somebody over to where where they are
where they are you got to meet the
person where they are and understand
what they need and then craft your
message and craft to whatever it is that
you're selling to meet them where they
are for the need that they may not even
know they have but but you've identified
so I think that adaptability you know
Peter had two nicknames for me the
chameleon was one and crystal meth was
the other uh uh you know I I have an
extraordinary amount of energy and and I
just and adaptability so I guess I think
you know a willingness to sell without
you know without fear and then you know
that high energy yeah I think that's all
right so to tie up just a loose end here
and bring this Boomerang back to the
initial question for a minute so is
Bruce Wayne to Batman as Peter is to
Charlie tuna are 100% they're they're
one and the same one and the same all
right so Char tuna he was a he was a
squash player really Peter Peter
influenced me in ways Way Beyond
business
like his
lifestyle I had never seen somebody with
that lifestyle what was his lifestyle
well it was like again you know he's an
old hippie who had been you know he was
playing the long game he had this little
business and he loved it and it made you
know a couple million bucks a year every
year and and you know good times he made
more and bad times you know maybe made a
million bite but it was it was a great
business and he just been chugging along
chugging along he had no Ambitions of
scaling you know I came in I'm fresh out
of college and business school and I'm
like well we can do this and we can you
know automate this and we can de and
he's like look shut up kid you know just
keep chugging okay and you know and he
would take off he' go down to biz for a
month and he'd go you know he a chalet
on the edge of a cliff in the middle of
nowhere in you know gaspe in in way up
Northern
Canada uh and he just go up and hang out
at this Chalet and watch whales breaking
the you know the surface uh uh and it
just he didn't Aspire for the things
like you look up to these people that
you think are successful and you think
wow and you try to model the way that
theyve live their life or the things
that they Mark as trophies of their
success and Peter didn't have any of
that like he just he optimized
for what I would say is freedom right
that that's how I've sort of you know
digested it into my own life and what
I've modeled he optimized for freedom
and anyways coming back to your original
question I I I go off on tangents
because I I he's truly meth yeah so well
he got the Charlie tuna moniker from his
squash he he was a competitive squash
player and that was his nickname was
Charlie tuna and he got me in a squash
and and yeah so what are the tenants of
Charlie tuna so or some of them yeah I I
actually meant to bring it because these
these tenants are like you know mantras
to me but you know it's it's a few
sayings that either he ident ified or
people that he worked with or you know
customers that he worked with for a long
time sort of identified as things that
he would just say a lot and they're just
these short little phrases that that get
a certain point across MH and he had 10
of them they were on the wall in the
office I've expanded it to about 15 I
still say the 10 tenets of Charlie tuna
because it just sounds better but you
know it's like I'm not Mother Teresa I'm
here for a profit you know cuz you get
you get customers and they they're like
well you know can you do this for me I
really and think look look I'm here for
business if I was here to make friends
we wouldn't be on the phone we'd be
meeting somewhere for for a beer but I'm
not Mother Teresa and I'm here to make a
profit right and and unabashedly MH
don't be backwards about going
forwards or what does that mean people
do things in these roundabout ways like
just be direct you know just just say
what you want to say do what you it is
you want to do don't don't you know
dance around it yeah don't beat around
the
bush there's one which I literally I I
I've still to this day never understood
which was don't crowd the MERS I don't
know what that one Meers yeah don't
crowd the
MERS okay there's still some riddles
unsolved yeah yeah yeah that one I never
got a clear answer to feel like we were
having sushi at one point in your like
something something like in the wh house
you can't run a wh house without any
[__]
I mean all right on its face this makes
sense but in what did that mean in its
original context it's like if we don't
have enough
inventory we can't do business because
you know it's an Arbitrage deal so like
if I don't have what the customers we
only have a limited pool of customers
like we're not trying to be Walmart
right so if I don't have what these
people want then I'm just losing
business and so if you want to run a
scallop shop you better have scallops if
you want to run a domain brokerage you
better have the best domains in stock
you know it makes sense but you'd be
shocked if you look around and you
examine
failures how often that's the case that
that people are trying to run a horror
house without any Horrors because
generally they're trying to avoid risk
right they're trying to you know der
risk I imagine some people listening
would say well hold on a second like
keep on to call Charlie I guess that's
fine but Peter ran a really tight shop
tight shop he seemed to carry much lower
overhead and fixed cost because he
wasn't vertly integrated like these
competitors which all makes sense so
they might then extend that to say well
if you're running an Arbitrage business
could you not identify the need and then
Source the inventory are you just too
slow like you've missed the window SL
missed the window yeah got it Miss the
window you don't have it it's a
commodity right so you don't have it the
the next call is you know your
competition yeah very little
differentiation it's a commoditized
product so you must have to get pretty I
I would imagine to make that work and
maybe I'm imagining incorrectly but
pretty sophisticated with forecasting
and prediction and so on because like
scallops last I check don't last forever
so if you're holding inventory it's not
like you can sell the next christm 100%
so I don't know how that deep down this
RIT hole you want to go but that was one
of our
superpowers was you know another way
that Peter had has has really influenced
me was Peter had lived all over the
world okay he dodged the Vietnam draft
and went to
Namibia and then he lived he's lived all
over the world and he's traveled all
over the world literally all over
everywhere and he had these
relationships that were just the most
absurd relationships everybody had crazy
nicknames and in Chile in Peru in you
know we Hado the catch we had Mr Lucky
in China and we hade
crazy really
like and he just knew these people and
and he would call them up and he just
say you know what's it looking like in
Peru what's it looking like in China
this year what's it looking like in
Japan what's it look and every morning
that was literally the first thing I did
every single like catch type of catch or
catch may not be the right term but yeah
I I mean a lot of these guys they came
to appreciate Peter and and his personal
ity he's truly a character and the
method but you know I would make these
calls I had a list of 20 people that I
would call every single day and I
literally wrote out a report of what
that person said every single day and I
presented it to Peter every day this
isn't a fast moving business and so
generally speaking whatever they told me
yesterday is the same thing they're
telling me today but and so it was it
was redundant but what it did is it
honed a whole bunch of different skills
and it caused me to build a relationship
with these people in a way that Peter
had built over an extraordinary long
period of time so it got them to trust
me it got them to know who I was and it
got them to share information with me
that they weren't sharing with other
people and most other companies had a
more local Centric focus on
Supply okay so they knew what the catch
was like in the North Atlantic but they
didn't know what the imported Supply was
going to be from China or from you know
Peru or from chilly where there's these
massive aquaculture operations that were
just happen to be at that time really
scaling up to match or now far surpass
the domestic Supply and that allowed us
to understand where price was going to
go and to understand which part of the
market so we didn't when you say you
know you got to have the horse to run
the
whouse you don't have to have all of
them you just need to know that the guy
coming in the door wants to redheaded
whatever right and so I need to know
that the that that the what the the
thing that's going to be short in the
market is going to be 340 size scallops
M 20 30 size scallops right what
whatever I need to know what's going to
be short because the stuff that's going
to be abundant I can get that readily I
will know the price readily I won't get
caught with my pants down on the price
and so I can do what you were saying
before which is like what we call backto
back yeah but by having the stuff that's
in short supply I'm going to get the
business because I'm going to have the
thing they need even if maybe I'm going
to be a nickel or a dime higher on the
stuff that that you know the other stuff
that's abundant we going to give us that
advantage that would allow us to compete
on the stuff we otherwise wouldn't have
been able to compete with we're going to
move
from tuna as in the namesake of Batman
Charlie tuna we're going to move from
scallops to hamon bar
it's a good segue we're going to move
from food to food okay it's a good segue
where does where does this fit into your
life story so I did a semester abroad in
Australia where I met my now wife who's
German and while we were dating playing
International Love
Affair uh she took me to mayorca where I
had hamon IO pan there's many different
names for it the Portuguese would tell
you that
the pigs are raised in Portugal and then
cured in Spain but you know
traditionally speaking it's people
nodding in the room yeah traditionally
speaking it's a it's a it's a Spanish
ham from the black-footed Pig and at
that time in the very early 2000s it was
illegal to import it into the United
States and when I tasted this with my
wife my now wife I was blown away it was
the best meat ever had in my life I
couldn't believe it and I was like why
don't we have this in the United States
and I was in you know the seafood import
business so I thought I'm going to
import this to the United States
backtrack to my college days you know
that was literally the Emer mid 90s it's
the emergence of the consumer internet I
took a class learning about the internet
I thought wow domain names amazing I
started registering them because I'm you
know hyperactive and every time I had an
ID I'd get a domain for it not think
thinking that these would be you know
valuable but anyways coming back I uh
thought I'm going to get some domains
for this hona bico thing and I'm going
to set up a website and I'm going to
start importing this stuff so I got back
to the us and that was my attention I
discovered that it was actually illegal
the FDA did not allow you to import this
hmon bico because it's cured for 18
months you know it's a raw meat that's
cured for 18 months in salt and uh like
french cheese the FDA didn't designate
it as fit for consumption so you know
that was sort of that and I I you know
put it in the closet and forgot about it
and then a couple years later I'm
driving to my office and I hear on NPR
radio that George Bush is about to get
you know the first hon verico ever
legally imported into the United
States and I couldn't believe it and I
got to my office and I found out who the
Importer was and I called him up you
know we're talking shop and it came came
up that I had these domains and it was
like his proverbial jaw dropped and he
immediately was like how much you want
for those domains and it was the first
time like I said I I bought a lot of
domains at that point already but never
thinking oh these are valuable assets
that I'm going to sell in the future it
was always like oh this is another lame
brained idea that I'm going to try and
build a business around that I never got
around to I didn't even know what to
answer and so I said well I I want one
of your
hands and he goes no problem done and I
was like oh wait that's too easy and so
I was like $5,000 and he's like done and
I was like well you know that Ham's got
to come from that first container you
know George Bush's container and he's
like done I was like oh wow okay and you
know I kind of was like all right uh
it's yours yeah and so you know I had a
few of these domains and and I I I
transfer the domains to him on the spot
and at that time I had no idea how to do
a domain transaction and so I just you
know took the leap of faith transferred
from the domains couple weeks later I
got a coffin in the
mail and the rest is history that moment
you know then gave birth to my whole
domain business I you know I realized it
this you know little
esoteric corner of the world you know if
this guy wanted his domains that bad
every business in the world is going to
want or need you know their respective
domain names and so you know at this
point I'm still in the seafood business
and I I was making you know quite a lot
of money for somebody in their mid 20s
and I just started backing up the truck
and buying you know as many domains as I
possibly could now where when do Tess
Diaz into the picture Tess Diaz worked
for GoDaddy M GoDaddy at this time again
early 2000s they launched what they
called I think the executive department
or something at that time they looked at
their accounts and they were like wow
some of these people have like thousands
of domain names like let's reach out to
them and figure out what they're doing
with these domains and so they set up
this little Department with a few people
and you know their job was to reach out
to these people that had more than a
thousand domains and figure out what
they were doing with them and most of
these people knew what they were doing
with them they had a purpose I did not
so anyways Tess called me and I was
actually in my car I was driving up to
my good friend JB's house in Upstate New
York I had a lot of time and so she
called me and she said you know what are
you doing with all these domains and I
was like I have no idea I every time I
have an idea I buy them she said well
you know there's like a domain industry
and and there's you know people trading
these things and you can monetize them
and I like I had no idea you know what
tell me more and so literally I spent
like three or four hours on the phone
with her getting a download on on that
there's a domain industry and
aftermarket and there's people on forum
talking about these things and there's
different ways to you know Park them and
monetize them and Google will pay you
for the clicks anyways this this was all
new to me but it was fascinating and so
I then spent weeks as I do deep diving
into this this new world of domain names
and I got super fascinated at this point
I'm married and my wife thinks I'm
crazy in fact everybody thinks I'm crazy
because I've now spent a a a consider
amount of money buying domain names and
by that point Yeah by that point mhm and
basically you know when I got married my
wife said look I'll live in the United
States for four years and then the shot
clock is up uh and then we're moving
somewhere else and the shot clock ran up
and it it sort of ran up at the same
time that I was doing this deep dive
into this domain world and what I
realized was there was nobody playing
Matchmaker between the people that had
these domains who were fascinating
characters like like literally you would
be hardpressed to find an industry that
has like such a motly crew of extremely
successful by a variety of Standards
people but from just wildly different
backgrounds wildly different interests
that have stumbled into this industry in
completely different ways I decided to
basically build a domain brokerage
business to play matchmaker and there
was people trading amongst themselves
you know kind of playing hot potato in
the domain industry but there was nobody
taking these domain names and selling
them to the end users that ultimately
could benefit most from them and more
importantly playing educator between you
know this nent asset class and the
broader business environment that I
think recognize like oh this is an
extension of our brand but didn't
understand why these things might cost
so much and why they're so valuable
valuable and you know the various
benefits of of owning them and therein
was born media options and my wife and I
founded it together and I think it was
maybe a year or two later that Tess
became my account rep at GoDaddy just
you know going full circle here and then
ultimately left GoDaddy to come to work
for me you know I went from a Lone
Ranger to plus one BPS sales
yeah and shortly thereafter you know we
moved to Panama we left Rhode Island
and move to Panama if we take a 30,000
foot view for a second for folks who are
unfamiliar with the domain SL dooming
world and I would put myself in that
category maybe I
know the edges of the puzzle but I
really don't know what the entire thing
looks like at all so there's an
aftermarket there are auctions xeres
dnjournal.com DN for.com domainname
wire.com expired auctions can you just
give us
an overview of what that world looks
like like I mean what are what are the
main pieces the
main positions so to speak like any
Market it has a structure there's a
clear texture and structure to the
market you have let's say at the lowest
level you've got guys that are just
really appreciate domain names and
they're investing in domain names maybe
they're hoping to strike it rich like a
lottery ticket maybe they're like me and
they just have eccentric ideas and
register domains around them you know
maybe they drank too much and thought
they had a clever idea that they regret
in the morning there's just people that
are sort of collecting domain names and
then you've got people that are really
taking it seriously investing into
domain names and they've got varying
methodologies right like I've got one of
my very good friends Yanni is super
methodical he's a robot he's got
algorithms that you know there's very em
very little emotion or anything that
goes into his formula whereas I'm kind
of the opposite I'm basically 100% on
Instinct and then I back it up with data
but I primarily am operating from
Instinct and then we utilize primarily
the same tools as like the SEO industry
to sort of gauge what the total
addressable Market of these domains is
and so there's a whole bunch of
different tool providers in the domain
industry to sort of uncover who owns a
domain trying to evaluate a domain based
on a bunch of data points there's a
bunch of different tool providers okay
then you've got forums where these
people meet less today it's less
relevant today um I would say Twitter is
kind of the the the X another segue we
can go down but um X is is really where
material domain world is meeting these
days you know there's just a lot of
there's investors cominging out at this
from a lot of different angles and then
you've got you know some of the names
that you mentioned domain name wire DN
Journal I would say those are the two
most prominent they are covering the new
news right these are these are our our
true journalists for the domain name
industry and they're talking about you
know policy changes you know domain
names are governed by Ian the
multi-stakeholder non-governmental
organization that you know basically
governs domain names remarkably
important organization by the way that
very few people know even exist and and
more people should know that they exist
there's all these different layers right
and okay and then you've got as the
industry evolved through the late 90s
and then the early
2000s you know these good domain names
get what we call type-in traffic okay
the it's just inherent traffic people
just inherently go to these domain names
like prime.com yeah prime.com you know
people people want to go to Prime at
Amazon they just type in prime.com and
you know we helped Amazon to get
prime.com for that very reason because
tens of thousands of people were going
to prime.com every day and not finding
Amazon right and so if you own these
domains though you can park them with
Google or Yahoo on on on their parking
feeds and they display keyword
advertising and then when people click
them you earn you know couple cents
sometimes more and at scale that can be
you know considerable revenue and that
used to be the primary business model in
the early
2000s was capture that traffic
hope it leads to click-throughs on your
advertising and then get paid by Google
ad just out of curiosity because I know
I'm not the only person who knows what
it is now I'm not giving a real example
but I'm typing something like Google
really quickly and I type an extra o
right Google three O's yeah and I land
on that page how much do you think the
owners of some of these misspellings I'm
going to pause for a second and because
this a really important point that I
want to make if your audience got one
point from me today I really want it to
be this there is a very clear
distinction between uh a domain investor
and a domain
squatter okay the guy that owns Google
with three O's is a squatter okay he is
the person he she whatever is the person
that gives the domain industry a bad rap
okay in the late '90s in the early 2000s
that is wor an a
you know it still resonates but it's
it's mostly worn off at this point but
in the early days of my business that
was the the biggest hurdle was like
you're just a dirty domain squatter
right it was like it was a it was a
really bad the fact that somebody was an
investor in domain names was a was a a
negative connotation MH you know funny
enough some of the biggest domain
investors are like you know famous VCS
that are funding the companies that are
accusing domain investors of being
squatters but anyways really so there
are VCS who own just oh yeah
spreadsheets full of domains more
targeted super high quality you know
maybe tens of domains but really high
quality are they holding them for
portfolio companies or are they looking
you know I don't know I don't know can I
play Stand in for the listeners for a
second sure all right so this this
differentiation I think is important to
underscore so squatter versus investor
yeah do investors still buy URLs that
are represent trademarks owned by other
people and if so how do you how is that
reconciled I mean there's always going
to be bad actors um but it is a very
very very small fraction of what it used
to be we've got cyber squading laws now
it's quite punitive you know
$100,000 if you get student in federal
court it's a $100,000 per name penalty
okay for for infringing on somebody's
trademark cyber squatting there are also
much cheaper faster and easier
mechanisms for recovering domain names
that infringe on your trademark called
the udrp universal domain
resolution protocol protocol I'm just
guessing I think it's protocol and
basically there's three elements and if
you can prove those three elements the
domain is going to immediately get
transferred to you okay and it's only
going to cost you about let's say
$2500 maybe three grand if you go for a
three person panel this arbitration and
they're going to
make a decision the owner gets to
respond if they choose to and in most of
these cases where it's a clear trademark
infringement they they don't even
respond and then that's it you're going
to get the domain name and you don't
need to know the identity of the nope
holder nope for that nope you don't got
it and there's very strong mechanisms
both preventing and let's say clearing
the market you know so it's there's very
little upside to doing this anymore more
and so like I said they're still Bad
actors but it's really it's it's a very
small problem compared to compared to
what it used to be when did you put up
your shingle and start the company 2008
I'm no historian but 2008 doesn't sound
super early in the domain the game so
which makes it more interesting to me
cuz it's not like day one of Google
AdWords where you're shooting fish in a
barrel right it's there there's a point
in time where I was like oh yeah we can
just look at the dictionary and go buy a
bunch of Dictionary totally but at this
point it would seem like you're buying
or matching or both maybe you could
explain the business model then what it
looked like which is incredibly
interesting because it raises the
question of how to value or how to
determine a reasonable price acceptable
purchase price M
and I wouldn't know how to begin doing
that for something like
nor almost anybody else like x.com right
I don't know who would use it for what
M I know it's single letter okay but
could you could you walk us through what
the business model was at the time
you're coming in clearly not too late
but certain lwh hanging fruit most of
the low hanging fruit have been a lot of
them removed
right all right and so then how do you
how do you determine a fair price taking
a wild guess here but it's you know just
for emphasis it's literally probably 95
98% of our business is domain names that
were registered prior to 2000 okay so in
2008 when I you know as you said hung up
my single and started the business I am
super late to the party okay now I have
started accumulating some domains but
most of them weren't really great at
that point but what I I understood that
it was going to be uh a very Capital
intensive business and I had already
spent a lot of capital and if I wanted
to continue this hobby I needed to
generate cash flow to support it okay so
that was one of the premises of starting
media options so then that premise
worked we started successfully selling
other people's domain names using our
commissions to then fund the acquisition
of better domain names for so people
would come to you and say I have fell in
the blank oh yeah I mean you're talking
and I would like to sell it but I'm not
sure how to do it a line out the door
right so one thing that is you know
there's a handful of domain investors
that understand what they've got and
they have no
real eagerness or intention to
sell except when somebody makes them
okay but everybody else is literally you
know they buy a Dom Main and they expect
it's going to sell the next day right
and so anybody that might can help help
them achieve that that unrealistic
objective they are banging on the door
so yes I get so many emails every day of
people that want me to sell their
domains right so endless supply of
inventory to sell I start banging on
doors and you know basically playing
fake it till I make it right because
nobody had really done this before so I
was sort of how did people find you at
that point most of the people that own
the domains I'm selling at that point
that's no longer the case but at that
point most of the domains that I'm
selling are owned by domain investors
right and so I'm meeting these people on
the forums there's DN Journal which does
this weekly sales report right and so
you know at that time today I'm like the
most discreet person you're ever going
to
meet but at that time trying to build a
business I was you know every time I
make a sale I would announce that sale
that would get on the forums or yeah it'
get published in D Journal that were
sort of a source of Pride was like oh
look my sale got published in thean
journal this week and people would see
that you sold a domain for a good price
and then double down on you know so that
was how the people that own the domains
were finding me finding you got it and
I'm finding the people that I was trying
to sell them to okay very rarely are
they coming and finding me it does did
happen right lightning strikes and do
you still remember any of your
initial sales where you're like holy
[__] I think this could be a thing do do
you remember the sale where I thought
wow okay I'm really I think I'm going to
be able to make this into a business was
pizza.net
okay okay uh which is this is a great
example
because it seems like there are a lot of
people you could potentially sell that
to so like so walk us through pizza.net
then so pizza.net was a unique case
pizza.net was a very famous domain
because it was
highlighted quite prominently in the
movie The Net with Sandra bulock in 1994
really yeah so in in this is a 1994
movie okay and Sandra bulock the first
time anybody has ever seen anybody order
a pizza online on the internet sander
bullet goes to pizza.net and orders a
pizza online and so pizza.net you know
man it's another rabbit hole but
pizza.net was actually has prior art on
a whole bunch of patents like Google
has the patent on here's your IP we're
going to provide you you search for
pizza we're going to provide you the
pizza restaurants that are within a
certain distance around your IP address
okay they have a patent on that MH
pizza.net was doing that prior to Google
filing that patent and so pizza.net
technically the company had so the
company that owned pizza.net was doing
that type of yes sort of proximity yes
the the company was gone okay but the
owner of the domain which he's also a
fascinating that's a that's another
fastc tring story but I don't recall how
he found me he he was a guy that
literally strung the internet cable up
the entire east coast of the United
States okay so he literally put in the
the the actual Hardware that created the
first internet Network on the east coast
of the United States okay ad I can't
remember his last name but Adam
something put it in the show notes yeah
and we'll also put the rest of the
tenants of Charlie tun in the show notes
for people who are wondering where those
might be found at the
time in the early 90s when when he
bought this domain I want to say it was
registered in '92 mind you most people
didn't even know the internet existed
till about 94
95 you know MH regular home adoption
didn't really happen till 96 97 mhm but
at that time in '92
94n net was actually the preferred most
people thought net because most of the
people using the internet were you know
Network providers these were isps they
were you know it was a you know read
only or write only Tech not in the way
that we think about it today but like
really you know Hardware tech
companies that were that were utilizing
the internet at that time other than
just putting up a splash page like a
business card and and they were using
net and so you know he had a lot of very
very good net domain names at a time
when he could have registered any of
them in so many ways to segue this but
you know he he actually is is the guy
that he originally
registered you know you brought up x.com
so there was three there's three onlet
doc domains that in existence okay
that's it three it's zq and X but Adam
why are there only three well so I'll
tell you the story so so Adam actually
registered all other 23 okay so so
numbers aren't allowed single numbers
are just not allowed for security like
uh prevented by Ian from from being
registered so he went and registered all
the other onlet Doom domain names okay
but because he wasn't using them so Ian
then decided oh this is a bad idea you
know nobody should be able to have these
one letters and so they pulled back all
but the three which they grandfathered
in because Nissan was using z.com for
their 300Z car which is quite popular at
the time I think it was Quest
Communications was using q and Elon as
it were was was using X it was actually
originally owned by a lawyer and Elon
bought it from him prior to merging with
Peter teal for for PayPal and so those
three got grandfathered in and and the
rest got pulled back basically I guess I
have read quite a bit about it I I think
the way I can was thinking about it was
like you know maybe there was an element
of security they're kind of of a
socialist organization and so you know
they probably thought it was unfair for
any one company to dominate a letter of
the alphabet but you know for a variety
of reasons they they clawed them all
back for three yeah okay yeah got it
pizza.net so pizza.net I you know long
story short I sold pizza.net I think it
was for like
$120,000 at the time which you know used
to be a lot of money and
and and I guess I you know I earned
probably a $20,000 Commission on that
probably the owner made $100,000 net
more or less that was that was that was
a lot of money for me you know like I
had this Mantra at that time you know I
had just left a job where I was making
about 400 3 400 Grand a year
consistently and I was 26 years old or
25 years old whatever it was and you
know that was I was making a lot of
money like way more than any of my peers
and and I literally jump ship moved to
Panama started this brokerage business
and I had a limited amount of savings
because i' spent most of it on domain
names and I had a limited amount of
savings and it was basically just enough
for us to last one year I had this
Mantra of every single day five days a
week every day I need to make $250
profit if I don't make
$250 then I am like already falling
behind the eightball okay but if I can
make $250 every day minimum then my
business Will Survive how did you arrive
at that number I calculated what my
annual uh expenses were going to be in
totality and divided by you know the
number of business days got it and it
was really that simple and I was just
and this is another thing it came from
Peter it was like look keep your
expenses low you know all my competitors
like they were doing sort of different
things you know but they were all trying
to be very technical about it and and
and you know build scalable businesses
and you know
lots of people and lots of technology
and you know huge overhead and and I had
you know at that time I had you know
basically no overhead and so anyways I
was chugging along and doing whatever it
took like I would give away a domain
name just to make $250 that was it
didn't matter like even if I knew I was
doing something that was going to be
harmful to me literally I was not going
to end my day until I made $250 and if I
didn't make it which was very rare the
next day I had to make not double but
triple to it was like you know just
punishment it was like okay so anyways I
really stuck to that and and I I I think
that that was a very powerful you know
discipline for me in that early in that
first year but in in brief because I
know a lot of folks listening are going
to wonder why Panama we originally
planned to move back to Europe you know
the sky was falling and so we thought
you know we really hated being in the US
where it was really just being inundated
with bad news all the time and we kind
of just thought okay well it's going to
just kind of be more the same in Europe
you know Germany would have been the
obvious Next Step so that was sort of we
we kind of said like okay you know we
really want to escape that environment
particularly because we're going to
launch a new business I need some
positivity like I don't i s what I don't
need is like constant negative Vibes
around me all the time and we left in
November and so it was like a bitter New
England cold winter horrible cold and I
remember my wife got stuck to the manual
car she was driving up a hill in
Providence and she got stuck and in the
snow and can imagine the German curses
yeah and so so anyways it was like look
we're going to we don't we're doing this
business that we can do from anywhere
let's go somewhere warm and I was like
yeah let's go somewhere warm and so we
kind of explored all these different
places you know we had visited a lot of
places in the Caribbean and we' gone to
Central America and we' you know I had
been to Panama actually you know couple
of years earlier because of a a friend
of mine from college that was
Panamanian and invited me down and so
Panama just checked a lot of boxes it
was on the US dollar most of my business
was going to be in US dollars so that
eliminated sort of the currency friction
yeah okay of of you know volatility
didn't even think of that yep that was
that was big that was that was a big
reason it was very safe I that time
Panama was the fastest growing economy
in the world from a GDP perspective I
think it was 13 and a half% GDP growth
in 2008 or 2009 whereas China was number
two with like 11% right so huge GDP
growth why was there so much GDP growth
well Panama you know is that like
banking sector or no well yeah so the
banking sector was growing rapidly the
Panama Canal was expanding we were
basically you know really let's say for
that first decade of the 2000s that was
kind of peak globalism right it was like
Wow everybody's doing trade with
everybody mhm you know that got sort of
short stopped with you know the
financial crisis but you know things
were booming Panama ticked all the boxes
that that was really why we landed on
Panama all right so so you're in Panama
pizza.net holy [__] this is going to
cover a lot of $250 days totally right
this could be a business it was super
important that I was hyperfocused on
earning $250 a day which you know you're
going to have a hard time really
building a big business if your focus is
on making $250 a day right so but it was
critical for that first year to to have
that small goal and be achieving it
regularly but then when I got my first
bigger win it gave me the ability to
like take a deep breath and then say
like okay I think this business is going
to work and I can start thinking bigger
mhm and you know I lost the discipline
of like the $250 a day but I started
hunting bigger fish with a with the
inherent confidence that came with
achieving this discipline of you know
hitting these small targets so hunting
bigger fish yeah this then brings us
back to the question of valuations and
acceptable cost M so how how do you
think about this how should maybe how
should people think about it as too
broad but like how do you think about it
Andrew and I got into the Weeds on
domain valuation we really got into the
technicalities which is super
interesting so be sure to stick around
to hear Andrew's answer related to how
do you actually determine an objectively
defensible valuation for domain names
fascinating topic but it got quite
detailed so we moved it to the end of
the conversation so stick around what I
wanted to ask about is something that
people might find surprising and this
is a note that I have in front of me so
and I I was surprised to see this was
startups in particular should not buy
their domain name they should lease the
best
possible domain name for their business
with the option or path to buy later can
you elaborate on this yeah yeah because
this is
a this is a big decision SL important
decision slash
terrifying risk for a lot of startups
I'm glad you said what you just said or
they wait and then they get ex extorted
is a strong word but I mean
you know they really get bent over the
barrel because they started is not
actually the worst case scenario the
worst case scenario is that they no
longer have a path to
ownership for their exact brand
match.com that's actually the worst case
scenario that's a much worse scenario
then we have to pay some exorbitant fee
to get our domain name okay and I'll
explain why about
okay 2014 14 2015 we started seeing
really like a parabolic rise in the
value of domain names all right I I I
don't even know really what to
attributed
to but there was a sudden sort of
inflection point where more and more
investors when I say investors I mean
really primarily VCS as well as startup
Founders and I think the startup
Founders part I I I understand that was
that that area around 2012 2015 was sort
of a lot of the guys that had a win or
let's say might have had a win but then
didn't sell fast enough and doom boom
happened but a lot of those like
early.com successes okay were coming
back for their second shot okay in that
sort of time period yeah it's true that
I mean I can can for sure confirm that
because I was in Silicon Valley at the
time and a lot of guys
who had their first wins like 2007 89 or
maybe that's when they started a company
and they had just taken some secondary
off the table so maybe they hadn't had
an IPO but they had they were flush with
cash and they were looking to build more
things yeah yeah I I I saw this a lot
100% so so I I think like anybody who's
successful they learned from previous
experience and a lot of them understood
that okay I launched on this silly name
and I might have gotten lucky and been
successful because the market wasn't
crowded but now the Market's crowded and
now there's a million people that want
to compete with with me and there's a
lot more resources to fund those people
that want to compete with me and so I
need a strategic advantage that my
competitors can't it gives me a moe okay
and a domain name is one of those
advantages and so a lot of repeat
Founders this is a trend that I see
firsttime founder pushes back a lot on
buying their exact brm match.com they
see it as a risk as you said most people
perceive it as a risk what I would tell
you is that it's actually a drisk rking
okay and a lot of well I want to make
sure we talk about leasing just not to
this is why we're going to circle back
to this okay now this is actually
directly leading into the le cool let me
let me just just to strawman or
strongman this a little bit if somebody
is in a weak cash position I mean it
could be risky
to overpay in the early stages sure but
this is this is where it's going to Dov
tail into the leasing thing okay because
I think regardless of the cash position
that you're in not regardless completely
but like you know within real within a
realm it's a better strategy okay
leasing than rather than an upfront just
allout purchase around that time 2014
2015 domain names really started to rise
and I was sort of telling you why I
attribute what what I attribute that to
but as the values started going up it
became harder and harder to sell these
things right there was less people that
could afford to buy them mhm and there
was some companies offering financing
you know at very high rates not super
attractive to most businesses I was
trying to come up with ways to increase
the pool of potential buyers and
increase my ability to close sales okay
and so I thought well we're all I say
we're all because I you know I also own
a lot of domain names we're sitting on
these domain names that we all know are
really amazing assets they keep going up
in value they're so underutilized
sitting in our portfolios like and and
really the whole parking thing which
used to be big business like we used to
make real money uh from Google with
parking but around 2008 2009 that
started you know it's been a downhill
slope ever since and you know we used to
get the Lion Share of the revenue and
now we get peanuts as the values went up
sales got harder and I came up with this
idea of like well why don't I just lease
you the domain I'll give you a fixed
price option okay so you have an
exclusive option to buy this domain
nobody else can buy it even if somebody
shows up and says you know I'll give you
$10 million to that domain that you you
know lease to this guy for $1,000 a
month nothing I can do about it okay we
use escrow.com is one of our biggest
partners and uh it's a thirdparty escro
service which I would encourage anybody
doing a domain transaction that's in my
opinion the only you know maybe you can
use a lawyer but other than that it's
the only safe way to conduct a domain
transaction used to be owned by Fidelity
and then it was sold to a private guy
and then that guy sold it to a
freelancer which is a public company
from Australia freelancer.com they're
the sole owner of the company now
anyways we're going to put the domain in
escort.com that way no matter what
somebody else offers me no matter if I
change my mind there's nothing I can do
okay unless you as the person leasing
the domain breaches the contract that we
enter into there's nothing I can do okay
you keep making your monthly payments
right off into the sunset you might not
even ever have to talk to me again if
you don't want to quick question so with
escrow.com who mediates a dispute where
you say that it goes to arbitration okay
it goes into arbitration and they third
part arbitration they they organize all
that or is that something you guys
organize I mean I am their number one
client I've done hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars in in in in sales
and knock on wood I've never one time
ever had a transaction go to arbitration
right I'm not saying but yeah if it were
if it were it goes to a third party you
know uh Forum arbitration Forum got it
okay and they they will basically
organize that like facilitate because
they're the ones holding the domain
right so they they've got an interest in
in sorting this out as quickly and and
amicably as possible they hold the
domain you know there's usually a
payment upfront which basically buys you
an option which in the you know the
world of Finance like any other option
you have an option to purchase this
domain at a fixed price for a fixed
period of time I generally default to
five years I think that's a great Runway
most businesses at a period of five
years are either going to you know Make
It or Break It Right it's going to be
binary right at at the five-year point
they know they've got a business and
they're raising you know either more
funds or they're profitable or you know
they've achieved some level of scale but
they either have a business or they
don't okay okay and so at that fiveyear
point they have and they can execute at
any time during the lease they can
execute after the first monthly payment
if they want to but within that 5year
period they have a fixed price option to
buy the domain exclusive to them okay
and then they have a monthly lease right
and so generally rough back of the
napkin math you know the way these
things usually fall is like somewhere
around 5% could be 10% you know the
bigger the value usually the numbers
come down the lower their percentage
Yeah so it's over that fiveyear period
you mean yep so the the the purchase
option okay and it's important that that
the startup have some skin in the game
okay oh I see that's the initial yeah
option cost yep got it not the total
cost over the five year no no it's going
to be the initial option okay get some
skin in the game buy yourself an option
and then you've got a lease component
and the least component is going to be
usually be like half a point right so if
it does that option upfront payment act
as a an advance in the case that you
purchase in most cases yes so generally
speaking we apply that option fee so it
let's say that the you know you approach
me you want to buy a domain that domain
is
$100,000 we agree to one of these lease
deals maybe you're going to put five or
$10,000 down up front and then you're
going to have a 90 or 95,00 ,000 fixed
price option to buy okay and then you're
going to have a lease component and the
lease component really you know TR true
lease okay the payments don't go towards
the purchase price but it's you know
half a point so like if it's a $100,000
domain you might be paying $500 or maybe
$1,000 a month right so it's a half a
point or a point a month which is going
to get the owner of the domain a very
reasonable conservative rate of return a
call it you know 5 to 12% rate return
which is going to account for inflation
and account for you know the risk and
you're going to have the opportunity for
less than a cost to keep your floor
clean to operate on your exact brm
match.com from day one and so that's the
first element of drisking okay is that
number one you're never going to have to
Rebrand which is a very for because of
SEO because of technical challenges
because of word of mouth and a whole
bunch of different things a Rebrand
while you're at Stride is very difficult
to pull off okay and and it's leads to
all sorts of messiness okay and
generally speaking it's going to cost
you somewhere between depending on the
you know complexity of your organization
between $10 and $40,000 per employee to
do a domain name Rebrand okay to move
from one domain to another one okay
particularly gets higher and higher and
higher the later stage you are in your
organization right and the more
complexity you have so you are leasing
the domain you're operating right from
the get-go on your you know you look
like you're a serious business right
from the get-go you're not try this or
get that so question for you on the cell
side cuz now I'm super interested in
this cuz now I'm thinking huh are there
people who just have a stable of domains
and they treat it almost like and this
isn't a Perfect Analogy but like a fixed
income portfolio where they're like I'm
not in the domain selling business I'm
actually in the domain leasing
business and but to run the math on that
model if you were in that
position you would want to know what
percentage just so you can forecast
properly you'd want to know roughly what
percentage you would expect to convert
to buyers at the five-year point do you
care though really
like I'm curious what it is if if so so
so okay so this is literally one of my
favorite
topics okay I this was part of the whole
revelation of creating this was was I
was sitting back and I was thinking to
myself like all right I've got about
5,000 really good domain names okay
let's just take the top 500 these would
all be domain names that like at an
absolute minimum you're talking about
$100,000 and that would be cheap right
so it's you know $100,000 and up some of
these are eight figures some of these
are seven figures some of these are mid
six figures BL blah right but $100,000
to many millions of dollars okay in
value the price I would expect to sell
them for all right if I just took the
top 500 domain names and I let's just
say I'm giving them away all right I'm
going to give away all of them for 500
bucks a month all right that's
$250,000 a month in totally passive
income right and and when I say passive
income like I I I would you'd be
hardpressed to find more passive income
right because not like a real estate
portfolio where like you know you got to
once in a while you got to piss off you
got to [__] deal with yeah you got to
deal with broken pipes and electricians
and you got to you know you got you got
local and state real estate taxes and
you got da da d d d d right [__] to do
what you get gross is very different
than what you get net right and and not
to mention the time investment so I I I
laugh when I hear people in the real
estate business talking about passive
income um but it truly is passive income
it's literally said it and forget it I
literally hand the domain off to esr.com
the servers get pointed to the person
leasing it and I get a notification once
a month that the payment was received
end of story like that's it that's a
pretty good gig when I did that math and
I was like wow I like those numbers you
know it got me pretty excited and I
started to pursue this and I I talked to
GoDaddy and I talked to some other
players in the industry saying you know
why don't we promote this as the way
that companies should sell domains or
acquire a domain MH and from there the
the concept you know evolved in my head
to the point where I I'm really at a
point where it's a no-brainer like okay
so even if you have the money like why
lay out the cash if you can leas it try
before you buy right like even if you
know you want to buy it and you have the
money to buy it like you probably have a
better use case for the cash flow right
just the in terms of like opportunity
cost it literally is going to cost you
in most cases less than you pay to keep
your floor clean in your office to have
this domain name right like like the
lowest paid person in your company cost
more than your company's branded domain
name okay per month so it's an no
brander in my opinion for almost
everybody when you go to raise funds and
you go to your VC I am you know vita.com
I'm an investor in a company called Vita
sold them the vita.com domain name which
is a good segue into
another element of this that you sort of
referenced but anyways it's a lot easier
to raise Capital going and saying we are
Vita and we have vita.com rather than
we're try Vita or we're vita. or we're
vita. XYZ or we're vita. you know it's
you're not a serious company it's like
you're on training wheels okay and so at
some point and most of the smart VCS
know this at some point you're going to
have to upgrade because there's a
ceiling you'd be hard pressed there are
a few exceptions but I think you'd be
hardpressed to tell me a company or
valued over a billion dollars that isn't
on a. com okay you'd be pretty
hardpressed and I think there's only one
Fortune 1000 company that is non on
a.com at some point for a variety of
reasons okay you're going to hit a
ceiling if you do not have your exact
brand
match.com maybe it's because you want to
go public and your investment bank which
was the case with Facebook right when
they wanted to go public the Investment
Bank you know whoever it was the
Auditors whatever whoever it was came in
and said look you guys need to own all
your IP before we're going to take you
public and so last minute they had to go
out and buy fb.com from the American
Farm Bureau and they paid $85 million
doll for it because literally a banker
told them they can't go public until
they wrap up this IP right or maybe
you're going to raise your next round of
funding and your VC says
look if you don't have your doc at this
stage it's a hug huge risk we're looking
for 100x here right like we want you to
be a 1010 billion company or aund
billion doll company and you can't do
that without your dotcom and so if you
don't get it at this stage then we don't
know what it's going to cost later or
you might not be able to get it later
and they realize that that's an inherent
risk right so there's a bunch of
advantages you know let's say
lubricating the fundraising process
drisking that process in the in the mind
of the investors um as well as you know
the downside risk of not doing so
and you know looking like you're not
serious or you have a short-term Vision
or you know you're not committed to your
brand so let me hop in for a second yeah
Vita you mentioned you an investor and
he said that relates to another element
of this what is that other element yeah
so I I I mentioned that just because
Stephanie telenius who is early
employees at Yahoo at PayPal at I think
2012 Woman of the Year in technology
phenomenal founder she approached me to
buy vita.com she didn't want to pay VI
okay VI yeah the Spanish word for life
yep got it okay she was you know
building this health Tech business she
wanted to buy v.com and she understood I
mean she had worked for and worked with
uh a lot of silicon Valley's most famous
Founders and VCS she was committed to
owning v.com and she didn't want to pay
the price I think you know I won't get
into the numbers but she didn't want to
pay my price okay I love that was one of
my favorite domain names you say that to
all the girls
yeah this one's my
favorite uh and so we were you know we
were working through ideas on on how how
could this work right and I'm if
anything I'm extremely open-minded and
so you know I was just throwing
spaghetti against the wall to see what
would stick and I was like look you know
give me a piece of equity in Li of cash
and she was like oh that's an idea and
so she went back to her bored and they
came back and we we we did a deal there
was some cash you know I think there was
some Milestone cash payments and there
was a a small piece of equity you know
valued at precisely that Delta right
there was no funny business I didn't
increase the price I it was just you
know we're going to make up for that
Delta between what we're going to pay
you in cash and what you wanted in cash
with Equity you say Milestone based cash
payments but were the what type of
Milestones like we raised this round and
we give you a little more then we raised
this round we give you a little more
even just as simple as time I see yeah
got it yeah so year one pay schedule
yeah yeah and that deal you know like
the leasing idea triggered in my mind
that wow I can actually act like a
venture capitalist but instead of
putting Capital money into these
companies I can treat these domain names
as capital and
interestingly I get the best position on
the cap table because in my
contracts if you fail I just claw the
domain back because the equity goes to
zero right and so that's an important
Clause yeah so it doesn't always work
right I mean it depends on who the
company is who the founders are what the
CH you know it's a negotiation like
anything else but generally speaking we
we've got a clawback clause MH otherwise
we need to you know Mark up the domain
you know to account for risk but we
started doing that and so now you know I
don't know we've got quite a number of
you know startups that we have a a a
piece of equity in that we've literally
invested in but we didn't invest cash we
invested a domain name in some of them I
invested cash on top because I was
excited about the opportunity but I've
thought about doing this with the
podcast occasionally just in a sense
because I do enjoy the startup game at
times I don't want to do it full-time I
don't want at this point to have a fund
or anything like that I just don't want
LPS to deal with
any of that babysitting frankly but if I
have as you do for
instance a competitive advantage in
spotting things that could become very
interesting right so when someone comes
in and you learn about a company that
perhaps hasn't launched or hasn't made
that Quantum Leap but they're on the
cusp of having bankroll to potentially
buy something where you have a
conversation you realize they're very
strategically minded analytical like
this founder you mentioned you're like
huh especially with that clawback that's
interesting super Diversified business
model and and it's a lot more
interesting than a domain sale right
it's like oh I I you know I get to come
along for the right so so you know this
comes back to another thing which is
that I I actually fundamentally believe
that we are still in the early stages
okay of domain names and domain name
value early stages
of digital Commerce and the internet you
know most people in the world have been
online for less than 25 years right it's
a pretty short period of time as we see
commercial real estate sort of dying and
all the distress in the commercial real
estate we're seeing the digital real
estate boom okay and there's a direct
correlation there I I would say a
causation so again what is a domain name
it's the place where you meet your
customer okay it's the only place that
you
own that you meet your customer okay
where it used to be the retail store or
the office or the you know whatever
right it was a brick something brick and
mortar now it's digital and that digital
place where you meet your customer is a
domain name now some people have argued
and they've for many years I've heard
everything you know originally it was
like oh I don't I remember when absolute
vodka launch launched the first
billboard campaign where they didn't
advertise their own domain name they
advertised their Facebook page and I
remember seeing that billboard and
thinking to myself how stupid like you
are literally at least I don't know 20
cents I'm pulling it number out of my
head but like it's got to be 20 30% of
the equity that you're buying with that
billboard is going to Facebook and then
when the customer goes to Facebook you
don't even own that relationship yeah I
you don't own the data you don't own the
relationship you can be shut off at will
like there's nothing you can do about it
right and that was before cancel culture
now it's like a serious problem I I
chatted with this guy ages ago he was
also sort of a Snake Eater in the
shadows not in a not in a bad way but
like he was very discreet he was very
ethical but he had these Facebook pages
he would buy Facebook pages that were
doing well and then 10x 20x these Pages
yeah and they weren't exactly rollups
but he would accumulate these things and
he had these portfolios and one of them
was just minting money you know I can't
remember what it was but it was just
like millions and millions of dollars a
month and I asked him what it was
like having and running that page and he
said it's like having the most
profitable McDonald's in the world on
top of an active volcano he's like 100%
because I just cannot predict what is
going to happen you know it's going to
erupt you just don't know when
mhm all right I want to segue here for a
second speaking of
branding [__]
yourself.com why did you buy this this
is remarkably timely as I alluded to
earlier in this conversation I get
literally thousands of emails a day okay
so I am like I I don't know maybe
there's somebody out there that gets
more but I'm kind of like one of the
world's power users of email I get
roughly 20 500 to 3,000 emails a day I
don't use a spam filter and because you
know really in my business you know it's
it's all about I can imagine a lot of
the legitimate emails are kind of
indistinguishable from what would get
flagged oh yeah absolutely just full of
keywords that are going to get flagged
100% right and so I I gave up on spam
filters years ago and I just you know
bite the bullet and I've tried a million
different things and always there's just
a some degree of of loss I'm not willing
to accept
and so I just literally muscle through
it every single day it's it's really the
only thing in my life that I'm still I
I'm captive to I've really optimized my
life for
Freedom except email email is still my
ball and chain so at some point it gets
tiring you get a lot of crazy people and
uh you know a lot of just just garbage
and so I had somebody presented me with
[__] yourself.com
and I thought wow I want to buy that
domain just to have the email address go
at [__] yourself.com and then I'm going
to create an autoresponder and so all of
these idiots emailing me I'm going to
literally just email them back from go
[__]
yourself.com and I cannot tell you how
much pleasure that has brought me I
don't know what that says about me but
it literally I it truly was one of the
best purchases I've ever made in my life
um just so clear everyone who emails you
gets an aotter no no no no no no no it
was selective it was selective there
were certain there were certain emails
that I then set up to be
autoresponders that I would get they
would be put into the file that would be
autoresponders yourself.com and then
other people I would just use more
surgically when appropriate and
sometimes inappropriate and but the
problem you know I I was I was having
fun with it and and and I still you know
I get a lot of pleasure from it but the
problem was that it turns out that
everybody on Earth in nearly every
country from what I can tell when they
fill out a form and they don't want to
give their email address the email
address they give is go [__]
yourself.com and so go with [__]
yourself.com literally gets over a
100,000 emails a day what yes so it is
completely unusable as like you know a
vanity email address uh but it is still
fun as a you know responder oh that's
funny that's funny you know what that
makes me think of I don't know why this
just popped into my head well I think
it's kind of funny maybe I've seen the
big laas too many times but I went to
Wine Bar uh Hotel Baron I think it was
in San Francisco at some point and this
was pretty early this was a long time
ago with a lot of the digital
signatures at a kiosk of some type when
you check out and uh I had had quite a
bit to drink
and it came time to sign and I I asked
the guy who was standing there it's like
how many people just draw dicks when
they sign and he was like about 80% of
the guys come
on I don't know why that's never
occurred to me but that's literally
going to be the way I sign from now
on all
right yes it's in exactly the same vein
pun intended oh God uh so brutal so all
right this this brings up if I miss
segue yeah from from [__]
yourself.com this leads very cleanly to
anger management so talk to me about
anger
management well I I attribute my let's
say evolution of my anger management uh
to you I I I guess it's part of the
reason I bought [__] yourself.com it's
you know part of the reason that I have
the reputation I do which is quite I
don't want to say belligerent but but I
I don't suffer fools gladly and I'm not
afraid to speak my mind at all times I
am you know the
self-designated counterweight to
political correctness I just like to
keep it real but anyways but a part of
that is is is anger I I I you know I I
have a deep I don't know I have a deep
emotional anger it's it's a fire that
burns in me and it's not always
there but when I get tricked Ed which is
you know fairly often uh you know it it
it it shows its ugly head and so I would
say that in my earlier life it actually
served me well I would have even called
it a superpower M but as I've gotten
older and as I've you know evolved in
business and as I've evolved in my
marriage and as I've evolved in
relationships it's not necessarily my
friend right and so I've had to find
ways to deal with that but it was you
know listening to a podcast that you did
you know many years ago talking about
you know yourself dealing with with
anger issues and anger management you
know it sort of was the first time I
even went oh maybe I've got a issue
maybe this isn't
normal you know it was that recognition
that sort of led me to sort of seek out
ways to start dealing with it and it's
an ongoing process I think it's a good
highlight of you know things that
previously served me that no longer do
MH right and then figuring out how
to it even became a part of my identity
both self-inflicted as well as others
for sure right it it becomes a part of
like and when it's your default you also
find ways
to justify it
or paint it sometimes in the best light
possible totally right it's like buying
that domain totally and all of a sudden
you're like this is my superpower let me
create a narrative around that it may be
true in part but then you you create
blind spots for yourself absolutely but
but it's precisely what you said you
create a narrative around it that suits
you you to justify it which further
ingrains it into who you are or who you
believe you are you know at some point
it stops serving you and and it doesn't
have to be anger it can be many things
many emotions or maybe many just
self-identifying characteristics it's
very difficult to then change your
software and say like oh I don't need
that anymore you know and I'm still
working on how to do it but I but I I've
made a lot of progress you know you need
an outlet for it so I started boxing you
know you need to reflect on it
constantly to understand what what are
the triggers you know and understand
okay when I get one of these triggers I
need to just walk away stay silent
whatever it might be but trying to find
ways to not engage with it right and
then always reminding yourself that this
is not something this isn't who I am
anymore or this isn't something I need
anymore this isn't a tool that I need
anymore it's really the way that I look
at it I wanted to attribute that to you
because you've done God's work in a lot
of your podcasts in talking about this
issue and how you've dealt with it and
that has sent me down a lot of rabbit
holes you know I I'm I'm very good at
picking up on these threads and then
diving down the rabbit hole and
exploring so well I appreciate you
saying that man I want to also thank you
for this beauty so this is how to keep
your cool and ancient guide to anger
management and this is by one of my
favorites of course sen the younger a
very controversial figure for a lot of
good reasons and this is I want to say
on anger yeah DEA and i' tried to digest
the original well not the original I
should say the translated
original and this has both this has this
this has both and it's very well done
and when when you gave this to me I said
you know what I could really use this
because I want to revisit it and I
listened to it on Audi book last summer
actually and found it incredibly helpful
and it's in some ways similar to an
audiobook I listened to which was I
think it's the easy way to quit caffeine
which is based on a method used for
helping people to quit smoking I think
it's called the easy way for quitting
smoking and it's it's a little hokey
Dale Carnegie is but the fact of the
matter is I stopped with a few other
elements and did 30 days with Zero
caffeine for the first time since I was
probably that is so unimaginable for me
oh I know I know but it was unimaginable
for me as well but it effectively takes
you through all of the reasons and
justifications that you use for
consuming caffeine and just dismantles
them one by one and I feel like this how
to keep your cool does something very
similar for me it makes me feel foolish
it makes me when I lose my temper it
makes me say you idiot what are you
doing you can't even control your temper
like what are you doing so I just keep
it on my desk really you know I
reference it but more than anything I
keep it on my desk and it's a
reminder that you know when some troll
on the internet pisses me off or
somebody I'm on the phone with you know
outraged yeah because they got an autor
response from go [__]
yourself.com how dare you how dare
they it's it reminds me it's there it's
in my it's in my purview and it reminds
me like keep it cool so you leave you
have this on your desk as a reminder I
like that yep maybe that's how I'll use
it hard to miss It's Kind like it's like
kind a giant stop yeah giant stop sign
totally all right so you mentioned I I
want to know if you have any
suggestions you mentioned you might be
the world's number one email power user
a lot of people feel beholden to
email any recommendations for folks
or are you just like hey man I need to
go to the email methodone Clinic too I
don't have any recommendations for yeah
no no I'm
100% the wrong person so I have
completely
capitulated and I really I just muscle
through it every single day I basically
accepted that I have about a two and a
half hour window every single day where
it's just clean the inbox so first two
and a half hours of my day almost every
day are highly caffeinated musling
through my inbox and then my you know
real day starts do you just go through G
Suite or Gmail or do you use other tools
at all or you just like I use apple mail
but our domain is on you know Google got
it so but I don't use any filters I you
know occasionally let's say every couple
months I'll go in and I'll do the
unsubscribed thing but like I honestly
find that the more you unsubscribe the
more you get subscribed to other things
I think that that's the the hook I am
for the first time in my life I'm I'm
optimistic I think that it seems like
low hanging fruit and if there's an AI
company super specialized in email
filtering please reach out to me I would
very much welcome your assistance but I
think that AI is going to be a really
powerful tool I think that what I do is
replicable by AI I tried it with an
assistant twice I've had an assistant
who would like at least eliminate the
low hanging fruit but teaching them the
way I think about it helping them
understand like don't delete that that
is actually a really good domain name
for XYZ reason and it's only this crazy
library of esoteric knowledge that I've
accumulated that allows me to see that
diamond in the rough I mean if you're
getting through, 1500 or 2,000 email in
2 and a half hours I think most people
are going to be astonished at the speed
I'm really good I'm I mean I'm I'm so
you must archive I mean a very high
percentage of yep yep a lot if there was
like a single place where I would be
like you and I differ more I I think
this would be the one it's like it's
pure chaos it's pure chaos like anybody
that works for me is like what do you
mean you just operate from your inbox
like your inbox is just a tool no no no
this is my dashboard this is like
everything is in my inbox
everything uh so yeah so I don't have
any tips or tricks I really just I
welcome the use of AI to I think
finally be able to replicate what it is
I do because it is repetitive so I think
I can use AI to do that so I've related
question which I've been sitting on I
took a note so I wouldn't forget that is
related to AI M so more and more people
are using chat GPT or
Bard for various purposes putting
together itineraries and they're using
them in place of say
Google the results are very different
and you one of the narratives out there
which I think it probably has some
degree of substance to it is that it
appears that Google got kind of caught
with its pants down a little bit with
with chat
GPT even though I've very high degree of
confidence and they will make very very
fast progress yeah but nonetheless it
was because there was a question of how
to use this
technology it's also a much larger
company and just has sort of minations
and processes that a tiny startup does
not however what I was going to say is
Google has the greatest Money Maker in
the history of the internet
MH so how do you capitalize on AI
without killing the Golden Goose is an
important question
MH I would imagine trilar as a lay
person
that these tools are going going to
affect the domain World in some capacity
how do you think about that when social
media came on the scene everybody pushed
back and said well my domain is less
important now I connect with people on
social media okay you're going to regret
that and apps came on the scene and I
was like oh your domain isn't that
important for me people don't even go to
the web anymore they just use apps and
then everybody has 2,000 apps on their
phone and it's like well I'm sure that's
much better right and now you know
there's lots of security issues with
apps and now Google is basically trying
to kill apps and so every iteration of
this of the way humans interact with the
internet offers up the fresh new death
of domain names okay but basically
domain names are the foundational layer
they're the Bedrock layer of the digital
world okay everything else is built on
top of that so domain names are some
super geeky technologist hard tech guy
is going to tell me I'm you know but for
the most part for the consumer Internet
domain main names are layer one send him
your auto response yeah I know there's
all these protocols that are underneath
that are really the layer one of the
internet I understand that but but for
the consumer internet like you know the
the part that matters to you know
e-commerce and and and and the consumer
domain names are layer one they're the
Bedrock Foundation of doing Commerce on
the internet if we were to stop
launching new companies today right or
putting out new ideas on the internet
because oh you can just use chap GPT or
Bard for that right first off I would
love to see the data but I bet you like
same as 80% of the people sign the
digital signature thing with a
dick 99% of the people using chat gbt
are using it for some stupid thing like
what's the best way to peel a banana
right it's like these things aren't
creating new ideas they are you know
really good at finding solutions from
existing ideas
and putting those things together in
creative ways and lots of different you
know useful stuff but if we were to just
like get lazy as human species and say
like oh AI is here we're done right we
don't need to create new companies we
don't need to put out new wikipedias or
new information or new art we literally
just stagnate because these things
aren't creating that next Frontier
they're literally only creating a
remixing a stagnant
of of of art I guess I'm just wondering
how those tools for instance and the
reason this is top of mind for me is I I
ran into someone in their
20s who basically uses Bard in place of
Google Now primarily because the point
she made was I don't want to click
through all these different links and
then click back and have to compare
these various things it'll basically
summarize put things into tables etc for
me in in a whole bunch of different
instances and so I thought to myself
well that's fascinating I wonder how
that will affect the SEO game and in
part affect I think it will tremendously
affect the SEO game and I think it will
tremendously or may tremendously affect
the formula for how to value a domain
but I don't think that it's going to
tremendously impact the fact that we
continue to need them in fact I think
there's an argument to be made that they
become even more important because
suddenly they become like your domain
name needs to be semantically meaningful
it needs to be easy to spell you can't
use these cute spellings where you're
missing a vowel or you're on a l or you
know because people are going to say
take me to Amazon right or buy this
thing if you're using an agent it's like
you know oh order me whatever it is but
you need to tell it where to order that
thing right and so it becomes even more
important to have a really semantically
meaningful domain name that's my belief
as for Google there's no way it doesn't
cut into that ad business right it's
just there's no way like ultimately
you're going to see cannibalization of
the search business I think that's
unavoidable yeah it seems to me
that Unique Products will be in a good
position if you are a Marketplace
selling commoditized products it's going
to be very challenging because I could
use an agent just say hey buy this thing
at the best price that will get
delivered to me in the next two days use
my MX on file boom done the other
winner I think that might emerge again
that addresses the SEO and the
competition game but wherever it's
buying that thing from they still need a
domain name oh sure yeah yeah yeah
totally totally agreed and I think
another potential winner it's like you
said I mean the the
demise you know the end is nigh for
Doc's I've I've I've heard that since I
moved to Silicon Valley in 2000 same
thing for email right email is dead and
I'm like email is not dead if anything
is more valuable than ever is more
valuable than ever and I think that is
going to continue to be the case as the
web becomes a mess of AI enhanced
misinformation disinformation and just
content spamming I think that domain
names are in my opinion yeah okay now
there is a lot of unknowns with AI all
right and and I'm not smart enough to
think all of that through all right
there may be a threat on the horizon
that I don't see for sure and I accept
that but in my
opinion there is more reason to believe
that domain names are about to pop off
in a major way because of a couple of
things one is identity and how important
it's going to be to be able to verify
real identity and I think that domain
names and I think that like Jack dorsy
is on this Jack dorsy understands this
and he's building around this domain
names are Central to everything that
he's doing so your domain name is
ultimately like shouldn't it make sense
that in order to get your Twitter handle
your ex- handle you should have the
corresponding domain name right like if
you're
NBC you should have got it so this would
be like. MB XMBC x.com NBC this would be
sort of like an very elegant like kyc
kind of thing 100% 100% so it's
literally kyc is the right way to
describe it sorry guys know your
customer stuff for people who exactly so
across the board from every aspect that
you can think of from Financial to
social media to e-commerce you people
interacting with the internet should be
identified by a domum okay because it is
a it's a really powerful way to identify
somebody so here's a question do you
think that's going to be it ties the
physical to the digital world it's it's
that bridge what do you think the
extension will be or what form do you
think that'll take what do you mean well
do you think it'll be I mean a lot of
people have eth a lot of people have
then you of course have coms but those
those can be pricey right if I
were do you have any any guess for what
format that will take I'm not going to
tell you a timeline okay but I think
that it's in in some future
most people in the first world that are
engaging with the internet on a regular
basis are going to have at least two and
in some cases three domains okay they're
going to have their real identity domain
name and that's going to be less
important basically the more public
facing you are the more pressure there
will be to have the Doom okay but
outside of that any extension will do
and then there's going to be your
pseudonymous identity in which case you
really don't care what the extension is
okay and then there's going to be your
uh sort of commercial identity whether
that's the business you own the blog you
run but you're going to have at least
two and if you have let's say you've
planted a flag on the internet in one
form or another through a Blog a
business whatever it might be you're
going to you know that's your third
domain name I think most people are
going to have two or three domain
names already today you can use Doom
domain name and you can use it as a
crypto wallet you can use the DNS
records okay without going too deep into
the weeds you can use the DNS records to
basically insert your crypto address
okay your Bitcoin address or your
ethereum address into the DNS records of
your domain name and then people can
send you know I've got drew.com right I
I can use that as my Bitcoin wallet and
I think that so first feature of why I
believe there's this huge growth coming
for domain names first is identity kyc
okay second is finance and wallets
specifically wallets because again it's
the same problem it's like you know yes
you can use some of these web three
domains these eth and you know I I was I
was one of the First Investors into
Unstoppable domains I was literally
probably in the first 50 people ever in
2015 to you know register a thousand.
eth domains right before anybody even
knew what these things were I was a huge
early adopter of handshake and there's
going to be a lot of people that get
upset with me you know so I'm going to
try not to poo poo too much but you know
I do spent a tremendous amount of time
thinking about these things and I'm very
deep in it obviously and so I have
failed to identify a durable use case
for web 3 domain names I think they're
cute I think they have you know some
utility like certainly in its simplest
form they make good wallets okay I don't
see a durable utility beyond that right
like it's definitely better to have tim.
e or tim. whatever like web3 domain name
and have that instead of your ethereum
address which would be some very long
heximal you know
string impossible for most humans to
remember also very possible to [__] up
exactly that's not the thing you want to
mess up right like it's one thing to go
to the wrong website it's an entirely
other thing to be sending money to the
wrong wallet okay but that actually
makes the point that's one of the big
Achilles heels of web 3 domains is that
there's no standard I I mentioned before
I can governs let's say the Legacy DNS
the the the root Zone if you have an
Unstoppable domain you've got Tim Ferris
dox okay they have thex they've got
wallet they've Gott whatever so let's
say you've got Tim Tim Ferris or tim.
wallet right okay easy tim. wallet and
you tell me hey send me one eth I can
send you one eth to tim. wallet because
today there's only one wallet but
there's absolutely nothing stopping me
from starting a new business tomorrow
that also has dot wallet or from the
ethereum name service from launching a
DOT wallet or there is somebody on
handshake that already has dot wallet
and there's going to be every single
blockchain is within the that you're
going to see that already this cycle but
over the next 5 years every blockchain
that exists is going to have their own
domain name service because it's a very
easy money grab and so you're saying
there could be bad actors doing bad
things with that amount of confusion
totally but even if they're not bad
actors there's just going to be a
tremendous amount of confusion confusion
because you say hey send me aath to tim.
wallet but depending on which wallet I'm
using which wallet software I'm using
like I don't know if that's going to the
ethereum blockchain is that going to the
handshake blockchain is that going to
the Unstoppable right which blockchain
is that on right and so I could send it
to tim. wallet and it could go to a
different tim. wallet okay and I have
there nothing I can do about that unless
I've got some degree of tech savvy and I
can pull down a menu and select which
network I want to send this over and
that's asking a lot of people way way
too much that's never going to happen
and so for that reason it's never going
to resolve the second thing is that with
decentralization I think decentralized
money is great I think decentralized
information is dangerous and it comes
down to one very simple thing that I
find most people can understand
understand if you go to the average
person and you say look there's this one
internet over here and it's centralized
to a certain
degree and you know people can shut you
down and da da you know but it's kind of
good enough it's the internet you know
and love but we got this fancy new
internet over here where it's totally
decentralized and and believe me like
I'm a Libertarian I'm kind of a
decentralization maximalist but I I've
drawn A Line in the Sand here for the
following reason and I'll just say so
the the peanut Galler isn't good berserk
um you are also we don't have time to
get into this right now but uh huge
Bitcoin Advocate yes right so let's just
just so people know like yes you're in
the game yes okay yes so please in the
game for a long time and have a pretty
deep understanding so if presented with
two choices of this here's the internet
you know and love here's this totally
decentralized new internet that has all
these fancy bells and whist that you
should love except that there's this one
flaw and that flaw is somebody can put
child porn and there's nobody that can
ever take it down and on that singular
point is when I made up my mind that
that will never happen the Department of
Justice Department of Defense which owns
the Department of Commerce which
controls the internet a lot of people
don't know that is never ever ever ever
going to allow that's wild
any browser yeah to resolve these things
okay so you've got some Fringe browsers
that do resolve them but I think it's
something like 98% of all internet
traffic passes through four browsers
right it's like Firefox Safari Chrome
and Explorer Explorer which you know is
probably a very small you know market
share these days but that's like
basically all the traffic and I can
promise you I would put virtually
everything I have on the fact that those
browsers are never going to resolve a
web 3 domain name
ever primarily for you know those
reasons and other surrounding reasons
like that the inability to ever censor
content M as
well as the fact that they then lose
control to sniff every packet of data
that passes through the internet right
and so that's never going to happen it's
it's not going to happen there maybe
some parallel you know like we've got
you know dark web now but that's it's
just this is never going to be a
mainstream thing ever okay but I do
think they make great wallet addresses
right to some extent today I think that
it could get messy so you have to be
careful it's funny the ethereum name
service guys actually are the ones that
figured out how to do this so they kind
of shot themselves in the foot but you
can now take a com domain name or axyz
domain name or a net domain name and you
can use the DNS the Legacy DNS settings
and you can literally make your domain
name a wallet
and so that to me is like an it's like
that's obvious where we're going to go
so I want to before just in case I get
excited and lose track where can people
find media options media options.com uh
we have a you know if you want to learn
more about domain names we we had not
O.co no I'm kid no no no I actually
recently I just sold O.co for for
exactly the same reason I explained I I
I bought it when doco kind of launched
into the public sphere you know was
always the extension for Colombia but
then it got sort of repurposed like I
did no I was kidding all right just
before we side Ally media options.com
media options.com and we've got domain
sha.com which is our podcast that's
about domain names right so I don't
suggest it unless you want to learn
about domain names and hear us being are
you active on Twitter I'm very active on
Twitter Twitter's the only social media
on okay Andrew rosener Andrew Roser
we'll link to all these things in the
show notes last question pursuit of
happiness small one so how do you think
about the pursuit of happiness because I
will say having spent time with you you
strike me as overall pretty happy guy
you got you got a little methy Edge to
you you know a little Twitchy a little
bouncy but you smile a lot of the time y
I don't know if you're crying on the
inside but you seem like generally like
a pretty happy go-lucky guy I'm a pretty
content person content content I I have
moments of Happiness I'm pretty content
I guess the way that I think about it is
that I generally want to be content
that's I don't necessarily pursue
happiness m i pursue contentment is that
wanting what you have or being grateful
what does that mean I yes I I I think
that's a another way of of of of saying
it but it's it's for me personally it's
a bit more that um you know so Terence
McKenna had this theory of novelty okay
that that ultimately that's what
evolution is all about it's just about
the pursuit of novelty and and that
resonated with me and I basically sised
that I think the purpose for each of our
individual lives is truly if you zoom
out and you look at it from a species
you know Focus as opposed to an
individual Focus the the purpose for
each individual life is actually just
novelty it's about unique
characteristics that make you you and
how you engage with the world around you
and what that leads to
and this novelty is actually the
objective okay or should be the
objective again in my opinion and so
meaning there's like a variety of
different characteristics survival of
the
fittest is that how theity not
necessarily I I think survival of the
fittest is is is a mechanic in the game
but it's not necessarily you know the
end all be all the end all be all of the
game I think it's really just about the
pursuit of novelty that that like you
need to do things that nobody's done
before you need to react to things in a
way that is not typical if you do things
like everybody else has done things or
like everybody else does things and you
can't expect a different outcome than
what everybody else has had and I
certainly am not looking for the outcome
that everybody else has it's just not
you know I you got one shot at this
thing I'm looking I want to do something
else I want to stand out I want to you
know pursue greatness whatever that
means right but I certainly above all
else I don't want to be like other
people I don't want to be like anybody
else like any other individual or like
any other group of individuals I don't
like labels I just want to pursue
novelty and what I found that to mean
okay once you go another layer is that
really
what most of life is is actually
friction and pain and suffering and we
have developed our society to run away
from that that that we're always you
have a right to happiness you are should
be in the pursuit of happiness and I
think that makes us soft I think that
makes us avoid risk I think that makes
us avoid uh pain it makes us avoid hard
work and everything that I've seen
everything that I
enjoy comes at the expense of pain
suffering hard work whether that's my
marriage right it it's a lot of work
it's a lot of you know pain and and
compromise but through that you achieve
love and you achieve you know this
amazing relationship that's
Irreplaceable right
through those days of suffering and
doing whatever it takes to make $250 a
day I was able to build a business that
makes a you know a lot of money and fits
my lifestyle I I've optimized it for
exactly the way I want to live right I
don't want to build I don't want to
scale it I want to have 60 employees I
want to have four five I want to just
keep doing what I'm doing just hone my
skill and hone my skill and just I love
what I do right but all of that takes
suffering and pain like you know I think
the best way to highlight it is like art
right there's no tell tell me show me
one meaningful piece of art cultural art
that came as a result of like rainbows
and butterflies and happiness right
great art comes from pain
suffering heartache mental illness just
terrible circumstances it's really it
great art comes from the darkness not
from the light but you need both and and
if you ignore the darkness you will
never get the light right or you'll
always be chasing the light the light
will always be in the distance but you
you can't don't you have to lean into
the pain you have to you know off camera
we were talking about something else and
you s you know I have to sit with it and
and that's precisely it you have to sit
with the pain don't block it out don't
ignore it don't push it away run into it
run into the pain run into the hard
stuff run into the stuff that nobody
else wants to do because that's how you
achieve novelty and through novelty you
achieve everything like you know again
anybody it doesn't matter what your
definition of successes I can assure you
that that person is successful by
whatever definition in you're you're
holding the to be through novelty right
they did something that other people
were afraid to do that other people were
you know didn't think of whatever it is
it was achieved through novelty okay and
as far as I can tell all greatness is
achieved through novelty it's doing
things that other people don't want to
do doing things that other people are
afraid to do doing things that other
people wouldn't even think about doing
MH and normally the Delta between those
things is pain suffering
heartache it's it's you know the
darkness which could take a lot of forms
right like could take the form of being
ridiculed absolutely right as an example
absolutely absolutely like and that's
just you know tip of the iceberg that's
like you know the Soft Stuff uh yes
that's the Nerf baseball exactly exactly
once you get through the Nerf bat
there's another guy standing there with
the real Louisville yeah so for yourself
then because you and I I think are cut
from similar cloths in a number of
respects one of which not just a bald
head not just the bald head and and
striking good looks not just our
resemblances to Jason STM but uh also I
think you wrestled I know I know your
wrestling coach and your experienced
wrestling had a huge formative impact on
you huge
and I'm not sure if people with high
pain tolerances gravitate to wrestling
or if it cultivates it or both yeah
Chicken and the Egg
problem and there are other ways of
course that people develop High pain
tolerances I think you could have
childhood trauma and learn to dissociate
I mean I actually have a lot of people
who have that experience in childhood
end up being for instance very high
level military operators a huge
correlation don't think that's a
coincidence and my question is if
related to my own experience I look at
Great entrepreneurs by the way usually
have Daddy
problems it's another thing to look at
when you're making Investments it's like
how's your relationship with your dad oh
it's great okay meeting's
over so well that'll be that'll be round
two with Dr
rosener unpacking daddy problems for
entrepreneurial success so the the
experience that I've had and I think
I've contended with to a large extent
but because I have high pain tolerance
and it has been a competitive advantage
I've sometimes ended up running towards
painful things that are not worth doing
MH right
which so it seems like it can be a
necessary cost if you are pursuing
worthwhile novelty but just the fact
that something is painful does not
justify its Pursuit right so I'm
wondering for yourself if you've how you
how you navigate that because even now I
sometimes hear the siren song like it's
tempting because I've been rewarded for
that in the past but as I get older I'm
like all right time is
fleeting this is I need to be more
surgical about how I approach these
things especially if I'm trying to
moderate my tendency towards anger right
which I think those two often go hand in
hand absolutely right so how do you how
do you think about that simple very
important to have Northstar right so
what are you optimizing for what do you
want right I I'm for me thanks to
Charlie tuna
I learned very I I was lucky that I
learned very early on in my career I had
let's say a role model not for
everything but for certain things about
how I wanted to live my life I I thought
wow you know if you were to ask me when
I was a junior in college like oh what
do you want to be me to grow up I want
to be like billionaire Tech entrepreneur
with thousands of employees in this huge
company that everybody knows and then it
was like Charlie tuna taught me like
whoa that's the opposite of what you
want like no no no no you want to like
you know definitely you want to Achieve
Financial Freedom but that's just like
step one it's like you know you want
real Freedom you want free will so I
optimize for that and so I decide is
this worth pursuing is this going to
help me achieve more or less freedom in
my life right like I was about to build
a business we were going to start a new
company called Pegasus about I don't
know a year ago now six months a year
ago I don't know and we spent six months
planning this thing out got a CTO we had
a whole you know we were ready to rock
and it was in the domain business you
know it wasn't like I was venturing into
something totally new it's a business
that I can I've never been so sure I
would have been successful in this
business like I know it would have been
successful but we got to the one yard
line we were about to do it and I asked
myself like I was laying in bed and I'm
thinking to myself like so literally
tomorrow I'm going to have this team
meeting and we're going to basically
Greenlight this and we're going to start
putting this in
action and that means I'm going to hire
a bunch of people and that means I'm
going to be flying all over to have
meetings and that means I'm going and I
was like I don't want any of that I was
like I don't even know like I don't
actually like there was a there was a
deep part of me that I don't know if
impostor syndrome is the right word like
I've achieved you know a pretty high
degree of you know let's say Financial
Freedom but my business most of your
audience would probably say my business
is like garbage like a it's and and the
reason being is I can't scale it I can't
sell it like you know you might be
surprised but I I I understand what
you're saying there will be a subset
totally traditional metrics of let's say
you know what makes a good business my
business doesn't meet that description
but my business is amazing for me and I
don't want it to be for somebody else I
want it to be for me and so I run it the
way I want to run it and I it brings me
back to a tenant of Charlie tuna if you
pay for the microphone you get to say
what you want to say okay and that
resonates for me and that comes from I
think it was Ronald Reagan who said it
in a presidential debate he said or no I
think it was George Bush
Senior and he said excuse me but I paid
for this
microphone and somebody tried to cut him
off anyways I optimize for freedom I
optimize for freedom of deciding what to
do with my time uh outside of email I
optimize for being able to live where I
want to live I optimize for being able
to move if I want to move I optimize for
spending time with my children
especially while they're young I
optimize for I eat dinner with my family
every single night at 6:30 every single
night 6:30 with almost zero exceptions
6:30 I'm sitting at the table having
dinner with my kids and my wife I
optimize to be able to like I'm going to
leave in 2 weeks and I'm going to
Thailand for two months and we're going
to bounce around we're going to go to La
we're going to go to Vietnam and I'm
going to go explore Thailand for two
months and I there was this thing inside
of me that like I hadn't built a
business that could I could sell and
there was this box that I felt like I
hadn't that was the driving force for
I'm going to build Pegasus Pegasus is
going to be a you know basically we had
a clear path that we could in five to
seven years build this into A5 billion
doll company okay I think we could do it
but I got to that one yard line and I
ran down the checklist of the things
that I want in my life and 99% of the
things that I was going to get from
Pegasus was the opposite of what I want
in my life and so it was like boom I
literally went the next day I told
everybody I said I'm super sorry but
literally just cut the head off the
Pegasus right like you know uh it's dead
yeah this is not happening yeah got it
okay that was so that answered my
question which was like why didn't it
get spotted soon right so it was that
yeah I have this driving thing I this
thing this itch that I felt like I
needed to scratch but I think it's
important and this is directly to your
point like you know everybody's got
those itches that they want to scratch
but ask yourself why where did that idea
come from that idea came because that
was what everybody else wanted to do
that was the the common narrative if you
go on x.com right now you know you're
going to see there's a bazillion people
that are you know startup porn and
hustle porn and it's like I don't I
haven't slept in four days days and
they're proud of it and it's like no I
dude I want seven and a half or eight
hours of sleep every night like I'm
optimizing for that you know and granted
in the early days of starting the
business like there's a lot of nights
that I'm you know not getting that and
there's a lot of suffering and there a
lot of pain you know but I was able to
suffer through the pain and the hardship
and the extraordinary hours and the B
Because I had this North Star I knew
that there was a light at the end of the
tunnel and that light wasn't some
ambiguous goal that somebody else gave
me it was actually what I wanted it was
actually what Charlie tuna had taught me
about how I wanted to live my life I
wanted to be free I wanted to be able to
not answer to anybody for anything
except my wife and literally just live
my life as I choose if you inspired me
right now with some idea that you know
achieve some of these things that I want
in my life close business tomorrow
let the guys run it and guys I'm out and
you know I don't know go live in the
Amazon like I I like I want that
optionality even if I'm never going to
take it I want that optionality at all
times and I don't ever want to feel like
I have to make a decision because of
somebody
else's agenda agenda priorities exactly
exactly so I hyper optimize for that
thank God for Charlie tuna huh thank God
for Charlie tuna really I I I I actually
if I were to say you know like the three
most important influences in my life it
would be wrestling you know from an
early age I started at five and and this
is hilarious because literally our our
coach you know salute Wayne Griffin one
of the top wrestling coaches in America
it's not you know say Ohio or
Pennsylvania he used to write in marker
across our forehead or you know in a
meat he write it across our headgear
pain is temporary pride is forever right
and I guess that stuck with me right
started an early age I was very lucky
you know my parents really modeled for
me I want to say this because I think
it's also one of the elements that like
you know defin success for me is you
know it's also super pertinent to what
we're saying it's like you know my
parents have been married 50 years 50
something 52 and I think that a
long enduring mostly loving marriage is
one of the most underrated elements of
success in the world maybe the most
underrated I am self-destructive like if
it wasn't for my wife man I it's only
it's a binary outcome I'm either like
dead or like I don't know eccentric
billionaire doing things that don't
represent any of the things I've just
described to you as what I actually want
in my life Howard Hughes putting his
urine in milk bottles
100%
100% I'm GNA save you that story but oh
W round two um uh daddy issues in your
anyway certainly wasn't easy but they
modeled for me what were the minimum
requirements to have an enduring
relationship and so that was really
important and then Charlie tuna Charlie
tuna really just you know took it away
what a [__] crazy story man your life
is amazing it's h it's so wild and every
every day I I really I really believe I
have the best job in the world because
every day I'm engaging with like just
super interesting people yeah you know
it's you and I have different paths to
the same thing yes 100% 100% that's why
you resonated with me like from the
get-go man I've been what an amazing
path you know to to just engage with
these high performers and you know you
get to hear a lot more of their stories
I don't ask them you know I don't get to
ask a lot of questions but yeah although
you know you get to have off the Record
convers ation about money and I remember
someone said to me they were like if you
really want to know somebody you got to
talk to them about their
finances and sex and they're like you
will know
everything about that person yeah and
idea for a new podcast I'm having public
conversations so you get you get a very
different side yeah you get the behind
the scenes yeah which is also yeah super
interesting not all the time but but yes
again I I'm an
extremely discreet person privacy is is
kind of like you know I'm a has to be a
relig has to be yeah Rel religion for
you guys so we're going to wind to
clothes get you to dinner with your
family get me to dinner with my team is
there anything you'd like to say before
we close up shop for the day thank you
it was uh really an honor to sit down
with you I really cherish it I've taken
a tremendous amount of wisdom from you
know you and your guests over the years
and so it's a bit surreal to you know be
sitting on this side of the microphone
but thank you you're welcome thank you
for all that you pleasure yeah thanks
man and I remember since our first
meeting talking about this aido scallops
I was like all right there may be a PL
time when we have to have a conversation
in front of some mics I you know happen
I I even when I was when I was young my
sister and I learned Japanese I when I
was you know probably 10 to between 10
and 13 uh couple days a week we went to
uh This Woman's house and she would
teach us you know origami and how to
cook and and speaking Japanese and I've
lost all of it so I'd be embarrassed to
try I think I can count to eight is
about extend to my Japanese these days
well you know you have that optionality
so tomorrow you could close up shop and
become a Buddhist punk in the mountains
in Japan that might be next year if you
wanted if you wanted all right so just
to recap where people can find you media
options.com
correct the industries leading
educational podcast domain Sherpa which
people can find at domain sha.com and on
Twitter ds. TV will take you to the
YouTube channel ds. TV goes to the
YouTube channel and Andrew Roser on
Twitter and will'll include also
additional tenets of Charlie tuna and so
on in these show notes yeah they are
Priceless and they should be in time
immemorial so yeah so we will put those
as always at tuned. Blog podcast and
people can find this and to everybody
listening thanks for tuning in as always
be a little Kinder than necessary to
others and to yourself until next time
thanks so much for listening to the Tim
Paris show Tata when I say hunting
bigger fish I mean it quite literally in
the sense that you know I said before
people were knocking on my door to have
me sell their domain names and now you
know as opposed to trying to go solicit
and sell these $5,000 domains $20,000
domains $50,000 domains I said I want to
go contact the owners of some of these
bigger
domains and Pitch them on having me go
sell these domains to an end
user and in order to do that I had to
have some semblance of an idea of what I
thought their domain is worth because
whether you're contacting a buyer or a
seller the first question yeah what's
the price what are you going to sell it
for yeah what are you trying to sell it
for right and so scallops houses exactly
doesn't matter doesn't matter what's the
price right and so I had to do a lot of
thinking about what am I going to tell
them and I'm not going to lie there was
a lot of fake it till you make it in the
early days okay1 billion
dollar 100%
you know you know some bad news bab I
didn't get the billion here's the good
news there was a certain degree of also
telling these people what they wanted to
hear cuz I didn't have a reputation at
that point or not much of one I didn't
write B you may have heard of pizza.net
yeah all right sorry keep going no no so
the absurdity of it is is not lost uh so
at that time you know this well you're
sort of a soft master of this in that
early 2000s mid 2000
SEO was really the name of the game for
online marketing okay it was that was
where people were really making the real
money okay and most people were guessing
on it but there was a few good people
that were that really knew you know how
to play the game and I got very lucky
I'm not going to say his name because
he's one of my favorite people in the
world he's he's one of the just truly an
amazing amazing one of the most humble
and just incredibly intelligent and and
just one of the you know by my
definition one of the most successful
people I can think of he's very private
so I won't say his name but he I I I was
lucky enough to get him as a client and
he basically said look he hired me to
actually go buy domains for him as
opposed to you know what I had been
doing which was outbound selling and the
domains he wanted to buy and the prices
he was willing to pay for them were
shocking to me and I couldn't understand
it and I'm a very curious person and so
I was really like you know I kind of
proud of myself I don't ask too many
question question of my clients and I
think that that's one of the things that
they appreciate but I you know when the
opportunity arises I I try to get into
their head and understand how they see
these things particularly as it pertains
to domains and other things that are you
know pertinent to me so I got to
understand the way he saw domain names
and I realized that even though he
didn't know it at the time it was
literally the key to creating an
objective valuation for any domain name
I had to tie it back to a way that
people in business could understand okay
to create a business case for because
people just flat out reject you right
because these domains are expensive and
they don't they didn't plan if I'm
soliciting them they weren't planning to
spend this money to buy this domain so
you know it's it's just very easy to
just say no so I have to have a very
compelling business case as to why they
should spend this money to buy this
domain I guess this is one of the
reasons for My Success was again I'm not
afraid to just throw against the wall
and so I would start formulating these
sort of algorithms are too strong of a
word and and make me sound more clever
than I am but these formulas
of how I could think about and how I
could demonstrate to somebody what this
domain was worth in an objective way
there was based on data that couldn't be
you know negated MH this wasn't an
emotional thing this wasn't a you know
intangible thing it was like look let's
think about what is the purpose of a
domain name and the purpose of a domain
name is to connect a business or an idea
with its intended customer or you know
reader you know many different use cases
on the internet let's stick with
business for now so connecting a
business it's producted services with a
intended customer okay you can do that
with an IP address which is ultimately
what an i a domain name is masking okay
it's it's an IP address but humans
aren't very good at remembering long
strings of random numbers okay and then
so that that was really the point of
creating a domain name okay and so if we
think about a domain name from that
first principle of domains exist because
it's a human readable format for getting
somebody on the internet to a
destination then what are the
characteristics of the domain name that
might make it more valuable than another
one okay and I thought about it from a
business perspective I said
okay when I'm if I'm want to create a
startup I'm looking at it from a
perspective of what's my total
addressable market like how big can this
business
be and I believe it's my thesis which
has seemingly proven true over hundreds
of millions of sales in many years now
you can measure the total addressable
Market the objective not necessarily
subjective but the objective addressable
Market of a domain name can be measured
through starting with search volume so
you can go to Google or any of these SEO
tools and you can say okay how many
people a month are searching for car
insurance just the words car insurance
and then there's an associated longtail
with that you know car insurance in
Phoenix Arizona new car insurance used
car insurance best car insurance best
car insurance right car insurance quotes
right so there's there's a whole long
tail associated with that and each of
those long tals is discounted to some
extent but but primarily we're looking
at the core exact match search volume
for a particular keyword or
acronym and that's going to give us the
total addressable Market Market in the
United States globally you know whatever
country you you can usually break these
things down by country and see where is
this market and then you can see what is
that market worth by looking at what are
advertisers willing to pay for that
keyword right there's a certain amount
of traffic going to Google searching for
that now I I'm for Simplicity sake I'm
focusing on Google here because it's the
one that people going to resonate with
the most but we extrapolated not
immediately but over the years we've
extrapolated this out to you know
basically measuring use in culture and
use in Commerce uh which can be measured
on social media which can be measured on
YouTube which can be measured across a
whole frame of different metrics okay
but for the purpose of simplic
Simplicity we're measuring how many
people are searching Google for this
keyword or acronym okay what are
advertisers willing to pay for that
keyword or acronym and that's going to
give you just those two numbers alone is
going to tell you what's the total
addressable Market on a monthly basis
for that keyword or acronym objectively
and then you can extrapolate that out by
a reasonable business multiple and say
okay well this this total Market is
worth you know I don't know
conservatively let's say 36 months okay
in some other Industries maybe it's you
know 60 months in some other Industries
it might be you know 120 months could
you explain that for a sec you know I'm
from Long Island yeah a little slow on
the uptake sometimes so what is explain
how the time varies okay so each
business or industry duration so to
speak yeah each business or industry
like if you're looking at you know m&a
you know one business is going to buy
another business okay there's generally
a multiple that these people will pay
right in each industry it varies and the
type of business so the multiples is
dependent on which industry the search
term is associated with yeah how durable
is this business right some I got it I
got it right so if it's retail versus
SAS versus is whatever yeah if it's some
sort of the hot new shiny object Trend
you're going to put a pretty low
multiple on it might be two years three
years right if it's I don't know
cabinets.com okay it it might be a very
long multiple because you know it's a
very durable industry there's not going
to be a lot of
disruption and you know the multiple is
going to be generally be a bit a bit
higher okay oh I see I wasn't thinking
about this correctly right so the
durability is a real Factor yeah in this
particular calculation y it's not just
looking at the industry and what type of
acquisition
prices it's both what what if they're
right it's a combination of of those
totally and again this comes back to
like meeting people where they are right
so I generally will not presume and I'll
ask them like if you were buying a
business in your industry what's the
multiple you'd be looking to pay right
and that's the number that I'll use and
and most people are you know they they
know that off the top of their head like
oh generally we pay three you know 3x 5x
okay so you know when I'm doing back of
the napkin I generally use three because
I like to just be conservative and and
and I find that to be you know the best
approach with domain names because as
you said most people don't understand
how to Value these things so the more
conservative you are the more you're
going to resonate so you multiply that
out right you got how many people search
per month okay let's just call it use in
Commerce and culture we can measure that
what are people willing to pay for that
traffic okay we can measure that
multiply those two and then extrapolate
out by the number of months that is
appropriate for that industry or
business that's going to tell tell you
basically roughly speaking there's other
variables but that's going to tell you
your total addressable Market okay now
we're going to look at clickthrough rate
and conversion rate okay and so that's
the next part of the formula is here's
the total addressable market and here's
the amount of that market I feel like
like I can re realistically capture okay
and this is where sort of the SEO comes
in so if you are ranking number one in
Google for a particular keyword and it
varies based on keyword and you're the
the number one organic listing meaning
you're not paying Google to be number
one your you're organically
ranking you can reasonably expect
somewhere in the 25% call it you know it
used to be 28 maybe it's 23 you know
maybe it's 18 but it's a 20 28%
clickthrough rate okay just for being
the organic first listing okay so let's
just say roughly speaking there's
100,000 people a month searching for
this keyword 28% of those people let's
say 25 free easy numbers because I'm
doing public math which is generally a
rule I have against doing but uh 25% of
those people are going to click so now
you got 25,000 people that are going to
come to your website okay and how many
of those people do you are you going to
reasonably convert okay and I like to
use 2% I think it's a generally a
conservative you know e-commerce metric
you know 2 to 4% but let's say 2% so
you're going to have you know about 500
people yeah 500 people per month that
are converting okay and multiply that by
whatever you would have been it's
basically the opportunity cost so what
would you have been paying Google to get
that and that's going to tell you the
cost of customer acquisition to be that
number one position in Google and then
based on a bunch of studies from like
Microsoft and and we can reference those
studies in your show notes if you want
but you can you can demonstrate what the
Delta is between having a domain name
that clearly it needs to be one of two
things it needs to be a brand that
people trust and or
recognize or it needs to have clear
intent baked in so the the domain name
needs to match the intent of the user
and if you have those two things you're
going to materially increase I don't
remember the exact number off hand but
it's it's a very material increase in
the conversion rate okay and the
clickthrough rate both so using that
formula we can demonstrate very clearly
the Delta between your cost of customer
acquisition on Joey's bofd donuts.com
versus donuts.com MH okay you're going
to have the higher click-through rate
okay which is going to give you the
bigger opportunity and then you're going
to have a higher conversion rate which
is going to obviously you know grow your
business and so that
Delta extrapolated out by whatever that
reasonable business multiple is is the
objective value of the domain name does
that make sense it does make sense I
think I'd probably need to see it so so
so ultimately ultimately we're taking it
back to that first principle which is a
domain name's
value is its ability
to Arbitrage your cost cost of customer
acquisition okay if we can reduce your
cost of customer
acquisition with this domain name okay
there's a value and then you just have
to multiply that value out by however
long you feel is appropriate for your
business to tell you what is this domain
name Worth to your business okay and
that is a non-trivial non- objectionable
business case that ultimately is what
led to my success in this business was I
was able to make a business case and
convert people where others failed
because it was you know it was a
mathematical valuation methodology that
nobody had ever seen before and you
could say look you can't H how can you
say no I'm showing you how I'm going to
reduce your cost of customer acquisition
which is one of the most important
metrics any business is going to measure
and
so if I can do that you know how many
months multiple are you willing to pay
me I guess the months multiple is where
it seems like you could have a
disagreement sure absolutely that's
where the agreement you know the
disagreement lies right yeah but I
understand it certainly doesn't have
100% hit rate right just there people
most people still have an emotional
block to I'm not going to pay some
domain squatter you know x amount of
money for this domain name just it's
just an emotional wall yeah and
sometimes I can break through that and
sometimes I can't you know over long
periods of time I'm generally pretty
good at at at you know converting people
but once people once it clicks for
people that there is a material
reduction in the cost of a customer
acquisition like I don't need to close
deal on that day okay it's like the
movie Inception you know the Le not of
cier movie you know yeah once I've
planted the seed in your mind you're
going to go home and you're going to go
to bed you're going to have board
meetings you're going to meet with your
Founders you're going to meet with you
know teams in your company and at some
point it's going to come up and and and
you're going to wake up one morning with
this moment of inception where you think
it's your idea that you've you're going
you're going to be able to scale your
business in a way that you otherwise
wouldn't be able to you're going to
launch a new division you're going to
you know start buying paid advertising
you some initiative is going to benefit
tremendously by owning this domain name
maybe a new competitor has launched
maybe there's somebody with your brand
name in a different industry and you
don't want them to have the domain but
something is going to pop there's going
to come a moment which is why domain
names are generally a very long sales
cycle but there's going to be an
Inception point where you wake up one
morning and you think okay I now I need
this domain and then you're going to
call me back or you're going to send me
an email and you're going to say hey is
that domain still available right and
sometimes it is sometimes it's not you
know another another sort of powerful
phrase that we've coined is off the
market forever you know once once these
things sell they're generally off the
market forever the moment a company
makes a decision to acquire this domain
name that they were fighting tooth and
nail not to buy previously MH it it's
basically Priceless to them because what
they then
say which is is so interesting to me
because they don't realize it before
buying it is that then they then say but
this is my brand yeah and you go well I
couldn't agree more but then why didn't
you want to buy it in the first place
right but the moment a company buys it
they they really the first thing they'll
tell you is no this is my brand I I
can't sell it like we sold it to
main it was quite a good price right but
I was fighting tooth and nail nobody
wanted to buy this domain okay it was a
very good domain price was very good it
was $250,000 for a domain that I would
tell you was worth at least double
triple that we finally sold it and
immediately literally 24 hours later
this I would say the David versus the
Goliath the David shows up and says you
know what I made a mistake I want to buy
it and I I just sold it this guy was
really really successful but he was like
he was like a ninja right versus a big
Goliath he was like the the Charlie tuna
you know versus the big Factory but he
had a really successful business and he
had some money and he said look offer
them I think it was like the example I
think it was $100,000 more owner said no
you know and this guy just bought he
hadn't done a single thing with the
domain name it literally hit his account
24 hours ago he hasn't set up an email
on it he hasn't even redirected the
domain name it's got a parking page on
it nothing zero he just is now the owner
we went from you know he bought it for
250 this guy offered 350 he said no went
to 500 he said no went to 750 he said no
went to a million dollars he said no
that guy tapped out and this guy was
just like I don't think there's a price
you know like it would basically be he'd
have to buy my whole business for me to
sell this domain because this is my
brand
and it's a very strange phenomena where
people don't they don't make that click
before buying the domain and the moment
they own it they realize how powerful
this is for their brand it's the most
important asset in many cases not in all
cases but in many cases it's much more
valuable and much more powerful than
their trademark itself because he who
has the doc there's only one and so like
apple wouldn't be app if it was Apple
computer.com they couldn't run around
calling themselves Apple because
somebody else would own apple and they
would be apple because the do com is
ingrained into people's brains with
trillions and trillions and trillions of
dollars in advertising since 1985 when
the first domain name was registered
right it's just an endless every sports
game has domain names pasted around the
arena right every News Channel you're
getting inundated with do right every
Big Brand that you know like it's just
ingrained it's assumed and so if you are
anything except your exact brm
match.com you cannot or should not refer
to yourself as your let's say raw brand
right if you're net orio or AI even I
would argue and you're not calling
yourself like let's say you're dares
from HubSpot he has agent. aai it's a
new little venture that he's he's
launched and you can't call yourself
agent on unless you've got agent.com now
because why not just to because people
are going to assume
you're if you're agent. then your brand
is
agent. and if you refer to yourself as
anything else you're going to lose at a
minimum you're going to lose 10% of your
traffic that that this has been done the
best study is from Overstock Overstock
try to do a Rebrand to
O.co okay as that's whole super
phenomenal interesting story that comes
back back to the one do onet.com and
whatnot but anyways they tried to do a
Rebrand to
O.co and they were obsessed with this
okay and they made an enormous campaign
all right and they did massive branding
massive advertising to promote this
Rebrand and they immediately like I I
don't remember I think it was like six
months maybe less they immediately
pivoted back to overstock.com
because what they saw was that they were
losing I think it was 40% it's like 30
to 40% of all their traffic was getting
lost right and why didn't they just
redirect overstock.com to
O.co is that a dumb question well no the
point the point was that they're out
there advertising themselves as
Overstock is now o yeah but then people
type in o.com oh I see what you say I
see what you mean and so and then it's a
dead website and so what does that say
what does that say about your brand
right like oh I I'm on a 404 page or I'm
on a dead you know this this domain
doesn't resolve page so it's very
detrimental to your brand and and you
know I mean I think Amazon highlights
this best like I I don't know what the
increase in in conversion rate was but
like just by taking away one step and
making the oneclick purchase MH had an
profound impact on conversion for Amazon
say that one more time please when
Amazon introduced the oneclick
purchasing oh sure it had a profound
impact right I remember at the time they
were talking about it like these very
small if you can remove just even very
small incremental elements of friction
between your customer and their Journey
uh journey to close okay with every
small bit of friction that you can
remove you're materially increasing your
conversion rate and and obviously Top
Line and bottom line as demonstrated by
the number of Amazon boxes that arrive
based on my 3 A.M orders that I think
are 100% important and critical to my
life path so ultimately right it's it's
that's what a domain does right that's
why Amazon bought prime.com because like
when I use prime.com like every time I
want to watch something on Prime I go to
prime.com I don't go to Amazon and then
click on you know my account and then
click on Prime and then go to Prime
video like there's five steps there
instead I just go to prime.com you know
this is maybe my one opportunity
to share the only I think the only
domain trivia that I have with someone
who knows domains a thousand times
better than I doing I'm sure you know
this already but do you know which
domain which.com forwards to
amazon.com that I know a lot of them I I
I sold most of them to them did you sell
relentless.com no so relentless was
actually going to be the original name
for Amazon that was Jeff bezos's you
know original domain name for the
Venture actually yeah before pivoting to
Amazon yeah all right so but they've got
a lot Jeff Jeff loves domain names I'm
sure uh when he was running the company
when he was still CEO they bought a lot
of domain names and we sold them a lot
of domain names and very strategic and
very smart he understood domain names in
a very profound way that most other
business
Executives don't and and I can tell you
that you know with quite a strong basis
because I literally have done business
with virtually all of them all of the
you know big
companies and very few understand how a
domain name can solve that customer
Journey MH the way that Jeff did and he
utilized a lot of these domains I mean
you know he was way ahead of the curve
you know he bought podcast.com which
forwards now to audible he bought
author.com and prime.com and tube.com
he's a smart man yeah very very smart
very ahead of the
Curve